oh
hey guys
hello everybody this is Ethan
you like that who's this I don't know I
don't know guys welcome to the show it's
November 18th it's so close to
Thanksgiving right
and we have so much to be thankful for
don't we folks most of all you all
watching at home who we love so well and
that's right Elon Musk who I'm just
thankful that
um you know he's a lot we're alive in
the same era as a great man like him
what an honor it is quite a it is quite
astonishing to see the da Vinci of the
Modern Age
me it's incredible actually it is kind
of a a
once in a lifetime thing to see what's
probably going to be the greatest
business failure in singular business
failure in human history perhaps I mean
and maybe even having something to do
with it
yeah I probably annoyed him a little bit
I don't know if I said I had something
to do with it but definitely annoyed him
you made a little dent in the decline
there yeah I declined the decline
anyway guys welcome to after dark we got
a great one planned here as usual lots
of fun to be had how's everybody doing
we don't have a ad today
we do have an ad today it's the teddy
fresh Black Friday sale
yeah guys this is the last week of Black
Friday and
it ass week so head on over to
teddyfresh.com up to 70 off wait it ends
next week yeah next week is Black Friday
yeah right it ends Friday Black Friday
is Friday so it ends at the end of the
weekend it ends Cyber Monday I think
okay
Cyber Monday yeah my rush mine day still
lots of goodies although quantities are
getting low so if you're looking for an
opportunity to get some fat discounts
which basically you know it's not gonna
be happening again here
uh
teddyfresh.com so go check it out thank
you guys for your support on that and
look at that
December 1st will be a new
oh show that oh that's crazy bro look at
this bedazzled ass that's kind of
everything isn't it
today this look for me is like I wish I
was amazing
I wish I was a musician but I'm gonna
wear it anyway it's the vibe and and
this is unisex right yeah and you have
the pants on as well yeah I'm wearing
small men's small so dope it came out so
good yeah love that there it is that's
coming out decem next month for the new
stuff you know how it is also quickly at
the top of the show here trading cards
have been going off the shelf folks uh
trading dot shop spelled weird
trdng.shop
100 of all the money earned goes to the
crew
um
the new pack here is just all kinds of
good stuff we've showed it but here
actually this These are nice pictures
um
yeah comes in these are great whose
finger is that who's where oh I think
that's um max that's Max yeah should we
take a close look I mean I was like well
manicured but interesting
I think he's
I think he's got nice hands
yeah they're good I wasn't criticizing
it's just like no isn't it just kind of
interesting that I could tell it's not
it's not one of us I knew it oh yeah you
know our hands yeah no I knew it too
isn't that weird like the complexion or
something it's just not right keep your
hands off my [ __ ] car
wow Jordan I'm so angry these days
anyway uh trading dot shop pick up the
pack
and support the crew 100 goes to them
thank you thank you to everybody who
ordered I guess I should say too that
the um the initial stock did sell out uh
the other day yesterday or something
um but the it's still available for
pre-order for the second wave of them
yeah you just won't get it before
Christmas but you'll get it you'll get
it you'll get it
yeah um also thank you to
thank you to uh uh Sean dub who says
free Ela which I agree with Ela has been
done so dirty do you want musk he's out
to get me bro yep next thing he's gonna
call me a pedo on Twitter or some [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] you know what I mean like
he did yeah you guys know what I'm
talking dirty thank you
um why Twitter is insane Twitter's a rap
he just got unbanned though Elon just
announced uh Jordan Peterson no longer
has to erase his uh insanely hateful and
inflammatory tweet towards Elliot I
didn't know that happened yeah he just
announced this part of England's new
thing well here let me pull up this
tweet he just put out um
oh one thing one other thing so see you
next Tuesday which is the members only
podcast is now live I'm doing a live
stream doing for members on Tuesday it's
super fun I did one last week it's up
now for members if you want to go back
and watch it but yeah members get a
live and extra live stream on Tuesday
it's great super fun for it after you
did it and it wasn't there I saw people
was I doing something wrong or it just
wasn't there well it's gonna be in the
live tab now this might have it's to do
with the confusion from YouTube I looked
even there I saw people saying that it
was very hard to find I don't know why
yeah I mean it's getting views it has
views so people figured it out but I've
I saw other people saying that
interesting why don't you watch it I
still haven't maybe we well there's a
members tab on the home yeah I know it
wasn't in that no
the video will be linked on social media
like Twitter it was like a day off so I
don't know if it takes time for it
instead of going to the community tab
you have to click the membership Tab and
then it's there it's so stupid
like I appreciate that you guys are
trying to do like new stuff for us but
like y'all gotta make sure it works God
damn dude well this means all of our
podcasts are in three separate tabs
there's the video tab the live Tab and I
guess the members tab as well so yeah
it's easy and not to be confused with
Community oh and not the community right
on the home page which was traditionally
they have this uploads which is
auto-generated by YouTube they stop
showing lives there yeah right so I had
to make up my own playlist for lives and
put it there on the home page so that
people could find it because we were
getting emails from non-stop from people
even big creators we got from who were
like yo what happened you deleted all
your [ __ ] oh no YouTube [ __ ] me in the
ass we'll do it live
that's what happened you know what we
realized uh yesterday too is they took
away the ability when you go to a
YouTube channel you used to be able to
sort the videos from either newest to
oldest or oldest to newest if you wanted
to go and do that can't do that anymore
what that's one of my favorite things
yeah you can't you can't go back in time
easily you have to scroll well I know
some channels turn it off okay so maybe
you check let me check video
oh [ __ ] me dude you're right dude what
the hell I don't know why they took that
away that turns me on that turns me off
Papa John anyway guys uh live streams on
Tuesday for members so thank you
everybody who's a member we love you all
so dang much appreciate you
I I almost I need to recap the Howie
Mandela episode because we didn't get a
chance to talk about it we got the
leftovers which was great but that Howie
episode was something huh a lot of
people said it was the funniest episode
of the show and I first of all got to
appreciate Howie for coming into the
lion's den let's be real yeah I've been
the main uh propagator of the Howie
Mandel Tick Tock and he came here with
open palms and here to break bread with
me and that that's pretty epic yeah I'm
also thank you Cam yeah I love that
camera's blooming that's gonna give you
PTSD every time no cam no
uh and somebody pointed out too that
he's probably
um I think the only person as big as him
that we've ever had on the show is maybe
Jack Black but like as far as like a
mainstream like not not internet culture
thing I mean yeah maybe
he's on one of the highest rated Network
television shows in America
and yet nobody watches this podcast
unless someone
yeah also I got to thank uh hunger FF
this guy was yeah
I mean
it takes a special kind of guy to just
drop trial and prolapse oh my God
through the roof yeah yeah yeah he was
very uh he texted me after he was very
appreciative to come on the show yeah
he's a thank you and well he's a great
guy I actually saw a lot of fan love for
Hunger FF he's just he's like a really
sweet guy he has a really nice
disposition and um and he's then of
another world it's Bizarro Dan where his
expertise is prolapsing instead of tech
yeah that's right jacket off well you
don't know what my mother talents are
why are you jacking off
that one doesn't it's so boomy it
doesn't even really sound like it's one
more time
I can't tell that I can't even tell what
he's saying wait what do you get off
I don't know all right maybe not maybe
not Damon said jack it off oh jacket
so we thought maybe we could work that
in there but yeah it didn't really work
out for us yeah but um
the first time he dropped trout and I
was so excited for this moment I wasn't
sure what how how he was gonna handle it
what but I was just like this was for me
such a great culmination of things to
make this happen
and the fact that we were able to reach
out to hunger FF yeah get him on board
get Howie in the studio it was really
like um the whole time he was like I
don't want to talk about the prolapse
and for me I knew like the whole episode
is about hours and not only that we have
somebody ready to do it for you live I
know I was gonna have a heart attack
like the whole time just thinking about
it I was so I was so happy and like
it actually went perfectly how he was a
good support about I wasn't sure how
he's a good support he's got a great
sense of humor obviously he's a comedian
yeah
very uh accomplished one
and so when um hunger dropped trout and
the first prolapse he did was like
really extraordinary I didn't look I I
looked a little bit the second time
the second one was nothing apparently I
heard that's what everybody said because
the you guys didn't for what happened to
the first one you guys lost the footage
yeah no I explained that we had that
Tech issue in the middle of the Howie
episode where Ian's computer crashed and
I didn't realize but it the feed that it
was sending to my computer froze at that
point but I didn't notice until his um
uh lower intestine tissue was uh hanging
out of his sphincter although he's asked
meat yeah excuse me please be polite
then
respect hunger he was a good guy yeah we
got a little bit of it's in the BTS oh
yeah yeah better not be in the beach
well not right I mean it was recorded on
his camera it will be censored it's in
my private collection yeah yeah
um but it is on Twitter we did capture
we did capture the full
first prolapse and it is on Twitter but
yeah how is reaction was it was just
great and uh that was just a great one
man his meat Mountain somebody said
Howie also went from what like 50 to 70
000 Subs so you know he got something
out of it right
do you believe how I've been thinking
about this a lot he says I thought it
was wet pudding he's lying he's
definitely so full completely lying he
knew exactly he said wow because like
yeah yeah that's the toe yeah my friend
wait what he says my friend Neil bent
over what is that got to do with pudding
my friend Neil bent over and this
happened I took it down okay he knew it
was a prolapse but he's he's lying
because he thinks the sponsors will
forgive him or something
I believe him but it doesn't make sense
for the sponsors I believe him you're
covering for recovering from everybody
for him I think even even though he was
talking about the sponsors I think his
bigger concern is his
role on uh ctg or whatever I think Simon
Cowell's like stink eye in him well I
mean that show is very wholesome and
family friendly and everything and he's
he's one of the faces of that show and
uh I just yeah I I it's just a little
bit ridiculous that
anyone gives a [ __ ] about that you know
what I mean I agree it seems like an
overreaction that's annoying like he
actually lost it sounds like what I
assumed this isn't what he told me but
he said it was a back to school thing I
assume he lost like a big TV spot for
back to school probably with staples or
something that's just a total guessing
Intel but that's probably like a fat
[ __ ] deal like millions of dollars I
mean maybe yeah they needed to embrace
it I mean it's one of the greatest you
should have been there with the rose in
hand bro
Embrace that [ __ ] he could do a
preparation a chat or something oh
that's interesting yeah he's lying
though I mean he did say it was an
educational experience for him so I mean
maybe they should teach that back to
school yeah I mean right
I think so hey I always think I forgot
to ask hunger
you know when you get a um
a prostate exam you put the finger in
you feel for a bump I think that's what
they're doing
but if he can prolapse for the doctor he
doesn't need
to get a finger in the butt they can
visually inspect it
right you don't need to come to me I'll
come to you I mean I mean that's kind of
good like because then you're definitely
not going to miss it if there's
something wrong
oh by the way this ad is sponsored by a
Polish hemroid cream brought to you by
actually that's true no way somebody got
an ad for procto
live in all poluska ow I love that which
is uh
hemorrhoid cream and polish what was the
the Hebrew uh term for prolapses oh my
God yeah
I've never heard that word oh I got a
Staples how we add on the Howie live it
was definitely Staples then I [ __ ]
know exactly what happened he lost see I
thought he was I was like what could you
have lost that was so big a Staples back
to school ad that's crazy bro that's
definitely seven figures for him
yeah sure I mean it is a national
campaign and everything
oof well then it's a little
understandable and he was a little
nervous I didn't realize I didn't think
that big right wow it made me realize
how desensitized I am to being canceled
right like what's the big deal right you
lose sponsors every [ __ ] other week
I also I hope he knows that when people
comment we will never forget it's people
saying like we love yeah we're
participating in the joy of the meme I
tried to explain that to him but I don't
think he understands
that it's all love you're very special
um
oh my God no this is the ad yeah it's
full circle no [ __ ] way I was
thinking that right because people were
meeting with that a lot oh no we ruined
it we didn't make sense because they
turned the ad campaign into the program
that's even better it's even red way
though that kind of makes this kind of a
high profile for Staples everyone's
thinking about Staples right
back to school no my God that's totally
what happened oh that is funny that
makes the story even
that much more iconic he was popping out
of the prologue yeah
can the things you're curious about
happen with the whole new Staples let's
find out
oh my God Howie this is such bad timing
I can't believe this
hey it's birthday boy what clock Gabe
happy birthday you
it's white cloud games
[Music]
my [ __ ] spend the night
did you start drinking already
someone punch you in the balls
[Applause]
Gabe you got the matching hat you got
the light I think the only thing missing
is maybe a chest tattoo
oh yeah
that would be pretty dope
would you get a white cloth chest tattoo
if I paid for it
I don't think so
artificial I want to be natural baby
yeah you like that natural look yeah
yeah happy birthday buddy how old are
you today
man you look chop you guys are a [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] yeah and Zach
especially Zach you better show up or
they're gonna have some problem
[ __ ]
Zach you hear that I did hear that I'm
gonna be there I'm unfortunately not
going oh no my friend got me tickets to
a concert I totally blanked I [ __ ] up
oh my God Gabe we got to get you in here
to hey Zach
we got it there's gonna be some problems
yeah there's gonna be a problem
wait can we break your knees Zach next
week can we bring Gabe into Haze you in
some way sure you heard that game I owe
that to Gabe yeah absolutely what does
that mean it means to we're gonna do
something terrible today via Gabe
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] facts eyeball baby
[ __ ] in that Zack's foreskin and tuck it
back in [ __ ]
yeah Gabe's probably not oh yours is
though yeah
yeah uh [ __ ] on a uh ear swab and stick
it in my eardrum baby
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh here's one use a wet wipe to wipe my
ass and then blow my nose in it
afterwards [ __ ]
you like that that's a good one right
there pH [ __ ] good job baby take a dump
in my hat and then put it on and wear it
all day
baby
yeah
well it is Friday so always a joy to
hear from White Club games who's 51
today
yes I can't believe that you're making
51 look good yeah good you look good man
eat it I give you 40. you're way older
than me though because I'm only 37.
[Music]
not oh yeah wait till you try to cook
[ __ ] I'll call you when I'm 50. [ __ ]
we'll have a party together baby any
strippers tonight
any strippers tonight you gotta be a
surprise baby okay okay I just say a
surprise it's gonna be a surprise [ __ ]
yeah would you let a strip her [ __ ] on
my chest baby
yeah [ __ ] on my chest baby would you let
her though would you let a strip
yeah would you let her
would you
some white some white [ __ ] diarrhea
white well we're not we're declining to
answer Gabe Gabe you're dodging the
question would you let a stripper [ __ ]
on your chest
I think that's a yes I think that's a
yes do you have yo brother you ever
played with okay
I'm gonna get someone to [ __ ] on your
chest okay okay
happy birthday
today
foreign
[Applause]
I'll tell you what I'm going to do for
you
I'll find a stripper who's who's okay
with this I'm gonna have her [ __ ] in a
baggie I'll send it to you and you
decide what you can do whatever you want
with it how about that and it's between
you and the baggie
sounds fair yeah yeah okay I don't know
if I'll like that one
you decide what to do with it you can
throw it out you can put on your chest
it's up to you
hey buddy happy 51st you're the man hope
you have a great night and I'm sure you
will I'm sure you will so Drake yeah all
right love you buddy appreciate the love
baby yeah of course man have a good um
all right have a great Thanksgiving
because we won't see you next week we
have Thanksgiving off oh yeah
whoo
[ __ ] in my turkey [ __ ] bye dude
God bless you God bless you it's so old
yeah it turns out Gabe might have a scat
fetish Mike well he was defiant we can
only speculate he said white [ __ ] what's
a white [ __ ] I go poop maybe dog white
dog [ __ ] oh I thought he said white
chick white chick poop no like he wants
it to be a white girl
no I actually heard white [ __ ]
I'm as lost as you white Club oh or
maybe he was doing a little play on
words there yeah I think he wants to
stretch oh maybe he thought stripper
[ __ ] looks like bird [ __ ] it's just
white I think that dude wants a steamer
on his chest I mean in all the best ways
possible
mean that respectfully of course
no Kink shaming
of course not I would never that's why I
said that's why I said oh you put it
I'll put it in the bag I'll send it to
you you do what you want with it don't
tell me human fecal matter happy
birthday graceful
yes graceful we love you peace and love
so yeah I mean [ __ ] I I still didn't get
finished digesting this that is one
thousand percent what happened there's
no question in a minute I mean the guys
coming out of a prolapse it's like goat
see what are they thinking with it from
the from the get-go this was Doom
campaign
yeah it's weird even without the
prologue but you know what dangerous
what if this is not it and now we're
causing this to get canceled it has to
it it has to be I don't know
yeah
listen whatever how he's flying whatever
happens to him is not my responsibility
that's what I've always played but wait
look love just sent this I don't know
you you might be wrong about this Ethan
because what this was somebody posted
this on the subreddit they were getting
served Howie Staples ads on the episode
which means the campaign is still a lot
can I can we can we please dissect this
image like his hand what's going on here
his hands were clearly were they shrunk
and moved or something he looks very
weird it's it's the angle
I think he looks great yeah I thought
that was an edit at first yeah it
doesn't look real no it looks [ __ ] oh
maybe no I think the ads real but this
image they use is crazy as [ __ ]
but this is clearly like a Christmas
themed thing with the snowfall because
he said it's a back to he told us it was
a back to school
um campaign so like who else could that
even be other than Staples uh lots of I
mean Target or or any kind of department
store kind of stuff there yeah well I'm
out here to ruin his career fully so
okay so that's I want to come here to
make him lose all sponsors
are they gonna claim us for watching the
commercial can you imagine if somebody
named their cat you like Lion that's so
cute it's just you look lines the full
name is that cute
I like it okay and then uh Sarah said
that my makeup looks amazing and I have
been following the routine that we all
practice
I wasn't sure today if it was good or
not oh you look sleigh okay it's
happening you're glowing it's like it's
happening it's happening
it's like more makeup showing and I was
like do I look like a clown or is this
how it's supposed to look what did you
say such a thing about yourself an
Israeli clown perhaps
[Music]
perhaps okay so I think we'll I think in
fact I was expecting you to play the
sound bite that just makes it really
weird you don't drop it after that it's
really
okay thank you I was searching for it
deep in there yeah it's not easy I just
left the hanging a little too long
he's this crazy is really clown
I think could make it believable you
have to include that he says H3
H3
more permanent than ever H3 he's as
crazy as barely clown comedian
yeah well so much for that huh
am I that crazy and I'm not as real I
mean I guess I am I don't know it's
three eight you are Israel and you are
crazy plus you gotta reduce me to that
but not a clone
not a clown
um and help them to see the evil doings
of Israel
from anti-israel yep holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
or what oh my God
that's not gonna play well with this
bass
um a lot of people keep saying I should
bleach my eyebrows oh I like that okay
I'll come think it's cool cool I wasn't
sure bleach the eyebrows yeah love it
cool get after it yeah all right I think
it's cool should I do yeah [ __ ] it
I'm the beer no no how long is your hair
Gonna Last for it was uh eight cents
yeah I think this is the end of it it's
already going back it's already like
going back to Brown
I mean this is all gray on the side so
that's like but you can see it's it's
somehow getting darker my hair defeated
the bleach
no it's just growing that fast
yeah I don't know man I mean it doesn't
look bleach it doesn't look like
anything it just looks like a [ __ ]
it's just okay and no no hate to Jackie
obviously it's my hair that's the crazy
thing here
I gotta say a mixed reaction to the
eyebrow dying okay I'm strongly against
it
I'm just so curious about the strongly
why do you care about what no I don't
I'm gonna do what you say I'm thank you
guys are super cool I meant to why do
you why are you serious why strongly
yeah what what's the opposition here
maybe I I've never seen dyed eyebrows
that look good
if you ever didn't like it you could
just use a tent to like cover it you
want to do a pull and then be bound by
the results no it's done I actually like
I like it if you're into it I didn't
know if you would like it I immediately
thought that's a good idea I'm seeing
more do it than no but I just was seeing
I mean why not it's fun dude yeah you
know what I mean it's gonna grow it
might look bad a little bit when when
the dog grows and it's like have fun
we're at we can do this [ __ ] we got jobs
where we can do it yeah you gotta do it
hey I I I've been thinking about
Olivia's um it's happening I'm gonna
tell Jess what what did the uh what did
the guy with the uh window uh maybe it's
not a good one what I'm gonna skip it
I don't know where it's going whenever
but when you hesitate yeah I'm I'm in
full agreement that's what I've learned
is that essentially when I say I
shouldn't do it do not don't do it
listen to that voice let me see if I can
rephrase it in a way that's a little
more palatable
can you write it to me yeah that's a
good protocol
um
I'll I'll just paraphrase I was saying
like if
I just think it's funny like somebody
who's in the wake of unimaginable
travesty and they see it coming and they
go it's happening it's happening like 9
11 you're on the tower looking through
the window it's happening you know Japan
the tsunami hits It's coming away uh
it's happening
you're waiting for the exact moment for
Cricket all those horrible things to
happen for real crickets
happening that's on Zach I don't know
why he hit you with the Crickets there
dude it was a wrong button oh
yeah I'm sure you missed that up
anyway thanks yeah I was looking for a
rim shot at least
anyway here I don't know if we're gonna
get claimed but I really want to watch
this Howie
you will uh
hold on I have this big memory of
Staples claiming Us in the past you
definitely did they're [ __ ] look
specific and why I think you're right I
remember that too I like that stands out
to me for some reason Staples goddess
ones dude the idea of a brand claiming
you for watching their commercials the
most obscene [ __ ] bro
we are we are Target
we are we are targeted
I'll do this on Friday before we go live
yeah that's actually we should warm up
not to be a good social pose
um you know what I heard Twitter's bad
but it turns out Elon is actually making
people say we are we are Twitter in the
morning couldn't get any worse could it
oh speaking of Howie Mandel
a lot of fans were checking out his
podcast
he had Jimmy kimmelon which I mean
that's a huge that's a huge get right 20
000 views dude Jake I think by the way
Jamie Campbell does like every day his
show he doesn't have time for anything
oh you know the late night shows yeah
they don't have time to breathe he made
time for it and he made time for this
and not only that he drove to [ __ ]
like Calabasas yeah which is like
he did all that for 20 000 views I mean
it's kind of embarrassing for Jimmy it
was 13k before so we helped him out a
little bit he's had Kris Jenner how much
does how much does Chris yeah like last
week what did they get like seven
thousand that's crazy yeah Howie pulls
crazy guess man
I mean he's Howie freaking Mandel he's
America's Uncle
yeah well turns out just like in real
life nobody wants to hear from their
Uncle Chris is 46k
that's a little better three months ago
even even Jason Nash with the Trisha
Paytas clickbait only got 62. hmm how
much does your episode have oh that's a
good question I like to check that it's
still the top episode I think you might
be right about his thumbnail and his
profile it's so bad I try to tell him
nobody you can't show the back of your
head nobody knows what is that and I
keep telling him I said Howie you're
doing people don't know your back of
your [ __ ] head why not just show your
hand or something you know it's so
Random
be better if he showed his ass now man
it sure would be Bill Maher is second
place I wouldn't expect that even Bill
Maher is so busy
all these people it's pretty crazy that
he gets them yo he got Paul Stanley
that's pretty big right Zach yeah that I
saw that I'm like what the [ __ ] Wilbur
Bobby Lee Jay Leno rest I mean well he's
actually gonna be okay he's not dead but
his face
it's happening he's on fire and [ __ ]
it's happening I'm more on fire than my
Korea guy he's crazy
isn't that rude did you guys see it it's
like a picture of him no show me there's
a picture
Olivia we shared it in the chat the
other day here yeah I love him in his
chamber yeah
is that real
he's in a hyperbolic chamber why are you
guys laughing about that at all I just
thought it was the Grimace photo this is
Jay Leno right oh it is what's happening
why is he inside of a hyperbolic chamber
you got a third degree burn yeah but why
is he first chamber wait I actually
don't know what even is this and what
happened to him he got in a car crash
well no he was working on one of his old
cars okay exploded in his face oh [ __ ]
he was on fire
how do you end up in a hyperbaric
hyperbaric chamber what is a hyperbaric
chamber it's like pressurized and
sterile and [ __ ] well that's why because
you don't want the burns to get infected
yeah it still helped I think that's
swelling okay okay I think that's pretty
standard for like severe it is I know
it's gonna burn victim in a hyper did it
get his face apparently yeah no it was
primarily his face that got burned he
was at like one of the best the money
makers centers in the world uh getting
treatments
there's a young 18 year old who just
passed away we're gonna get his face
we're gonna put his face away is this
really serious yeah but it's Jalen also
it's fine do you like pink you saved me
from this because I wanted a a vintage
car this was gonna happen to me
and by the way why are you saying no ELO
really wanted a vintage car I knew that
was a bad idea when you almost crashed
no no yeah I know I remember that let's
not talk about that but you know I was
gonna get the car was gonna get stuck on
the side of the freeway
I would open the the thing to see what's
going on and it would blow up in my face
no collectible cars thank you thank you
unlike Teslas that never explode well by
the way it's I believe it's hyperbaric
chamber hyperbolic is what yeah
cell
dude
he's gonna get his ass kicked he looks
good that was gonna rock his [ __ ] from
what I can tell he looks good if you
only have some peace and quiet in here
when I can tell he looks good dude
that's like a [ __ ] mummy
yo stop this picture needs to go on Wiki
immediately
it has been a hyperbaric chamber
probably already there oh that's so
funny holy [ __ ]
should I send that picture to seaman
right now
I'm curious about anything I mean his
feet look good oh I'm gonna send it I
mean he he's a busy guy
um so he might not get back to us
immediately but yeah he'll get back to
us when it's a matter of feet he he
finds time
um
but anyway we're talking about
wonderful Howie Mandel who
um he had Jimmy kimmelon yeah and by the
way while I'm while I'm critiquing your
show and I'm sorry but this this is the
worst lighting I've ever seen it's so
bad right there I mean what's what's
going on here uh just to show the poor
Jimmy it's like so hot and then
breakfast yeah yeah it's crazy this is
Howie Mandel he's got a whole big you
know what I mean like what kind of crazy
ass lighting is this
can we talk about how good Howie looks
for his age oh my god oh he's killing it
it's phenomenal yeah their shot looks
great
look how great their shot looks and then
you go Jimmy Kimmel
um ghoul what is it Halloween
this bag is under his eyes we kind of
knew this because a similar thing
happened to you right with the I guess
it was more about the angle with you but
he he fixed the angle listen he has a
history of unflattering his uh whoa yes
that is actually very bad too so but
wait I remember when YouTubers used to
make their videos look like that because
it was flattering it removes their pores
yeah it's awesome
it's a Jimmy Lee filter
overlay wait what happened Dan
what do you mean what happened you said
hold on yeah oh when he had it all
bright I was gonna come make it even
brighter but the moments passed so okay
so anyway speak so he had Jimmy kimmelon
and uh people have been going and
watching after his appearance here and
um well watch this transition did
somebody noticed it's really phenomenal
check this out you gotta do a show
tonight and there's a big shooting in
your hometown and people were killed and
uh uh you know and look at you we were
in a commercial now and look at Jack
laughs
so did y'all just drop that in there and
nobody watch that back
so sorry to interrupt he's got a whole
class crew for this in town and people
were killed and uh uh you know and look
at you yeah you're in a commercial now
and the way that it's just so abruptly
boom anyway
[ __ ] what he was talking about that's
good man I love it and they're laughing
too yeah
look at Jackie I'm looking good right
but if you're just listening I'm telling
you she's looking good you know why
because you're wearing one of our
sponsors products you are wearing Shady
Rays
there you go brought to you by uh new
Las Vegas uh mass shooting
what that's what he said that's what
they said he said brought to you by the
mass shooting in Vegas
it's happening is what they yep
well now and God
every time there's a tragedy from now on
what's happening big shooting in your
hometown and people were killed and uh
uh you know I didn't even realize that's
what he was talking about yeah I mean it
has to be yeah he's from Vegas yeah yeah
look at you
somebody survived the shooting
why did they put it there it's so it
feels like it's listen these are all
mistakes that we've done too yeah yeah
yeah that's right listen
we did oh our you know we did uh so
sorry we got to go to break yeah I
believe is it um you had the the
original video pulled up right what time
stamp does the ad happen at does it
happen like exactly at 30 minutes or
like exactly in 15 minutes or something
listen you got to do a show tonight and
there's a big shooting in town and
people were killed and uh uh you know
and yeah it could not even more random
time yeah I think they were just like
okay I don't even think they're
listening they're just like okay there's
a spot boom boom drop it they do that a
couple times throughout the episode but
this was done
maybe they have like a 20 and a 40
minute I mean we do our mid rolls kind
of like that right then we just do 10
minutes 20 minutes true the the YouTube
minerals probably do good inserted into
some unfortunate moments Howie I hope
you're watching this
he says he watches and I believe him
actually he seemed to know he catches
the lore yeah oh look at all the nice
comments from H3 fam all from the H3
family we all love you Howie there was
never any hate what you did on Tick Tock
may have lost you two sponsors but that
Tick Tock showed us a more human side of
you than AGT ever could this has gained
you a more loyal following that will
make those sponsors come crawling back
wow Jared Dorsey what a insightful
comment oh yeah Jared
wow that's awesome good good people I
love how you guys are so supportive of
our guests it's very nice to see
this is the last foot oh my God this is
the LA are you serious or is that a joke
uh no that's why Avery told me about our
mom this is the last photo of of Jay
lenoons bro you know these guys they're
like the two dip shits from Tick Tock oh
God DaVinci
DaVinci Morrow's twins I think it's so
funny that we're talking about him like
he's dead
I
have like a slight dislike for Jalen
it's not passionate but like
as a Howard Stern fan he [ __ ] hates
Jay Leno like hates him because he
[ __ ] over Conan O'Brien on the late
night right you've been conditioned he's
kind of a legendary [ __ ] he's not
really a good guy I mean not that I want
his face to get pregnant oh no no but
for bed he's coming for your hairline
though dude he has a phenomenal hair
that's true that's true I'm being
intimidating can't take that from him
how old is he that's a beautiful
hairline he's he's up there for sure
golly that's a nice probably seven he's
72 yeah I'm up there and I went up in
Flames too
oh dude I [ __ ] hate if my last photo
alive was with these [ __ ] idiots
[Music]
I know in cars bro he has a tough time
that video of him almost dying on the
race track so bad why can't we show it
because it's from a TV show it'll for
sure just that one like two second clip
it's so good Ethan it's we've watched it
before not on the show I don't remember
it
I don't know if I watched it how long is
it see if you can slice it down we'll
make it a small box
it's you will they're gonna get you or a
gif can you find a gift of it that might
be possible maybe maybe
the sound is so so a part of it though
it really is the sound is a part of it
here's a still here's a still thank you
Cameron oh well that's okay whoa really
that happened to him
his car window is open when this
happened so this is this is a drag car
that goes like this 2 000 horsepower or
something like that and it the video is
[ __ ] amazing
it's happening
the car is upside down at this point and
the window is open yeah he almost lost
his hand so the thing is he walked away
with it he walked away from this
incident completely uninjured which is
incredible when you see the video uh
basically
gasoline if you send a car that flips
over about like 12 times like so
violently and uh somehow walked away and
why is that funny to you Dan because
V camera directly on his face as he's
getting rattled around and this The
Stunt Driver driving the car is like 87
years old or something he's like a drag
drag race Legend yeah and he died no no
no no nobody died No in fact he's fine
too it's like kind of incredible uh but
my God by the way Alicia uh for the
record thank you for the Dono it says
bleach eyebrows would be stunning on you
though
the wildest thing about that video too
is that they don't even click bait the
uh flip it's just a regular old video it
says Jay Leno goes 25 000
it just happens out of the blue there's
no like warning and it just all of a
sudden the car is just flipping over and
over and over again yeah it's happening
um um yeah so anyway what the lore with
Jay Leno is like he
retired and Conan O'Brien was announced
he had been hired he left his previous
job he was going to take the slot and
then Jay Leno was like you know what I I
actually want to stay on you know I
think I think I'm gonna stay I said they
had the kick Conan out
and Jay Leno went back I don't know
Howard's friends with Conan and he hates
Jay Leno's guts so it's rubbed off on me
a little bit I I'm the same way with you
uh based on Howard's opinion and
judgment yeah I mean yeah he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but but I mean to be fair the
burning probably couldn't have made his
face that much worse right
no good
rough I Rim shot a little bit funny I
mean damn all right [ __ ] sorry about
that one
the main Broski thank you for the gifted
appreciate you
I'll never forget man though Bill Burr
went on Jay Leno and yeah and he goes
man you got to be one of the weirdest
looking [ __ ] that ever lived I
had never seen anyone with the face like
yours just straight to his face it was
just amazing
it's so true
yeah man [ __ ] this is the last image you
see before you die
that's it bro hell no
hell no dude
hell not but I'd rather be not being
born they're dating twins
and everybody's dressed the same
look at homie on the left man he's he's
more handsome I gotta say this twin got
the handsome Gene and this one got the
goofy as [ __ ] Gene
it's just the haircut is awful this is
awful
awful okay enough of that we actually
have a show to do believe it or not hmm
having too much fun though
yeah it's too much fun
so how we we love you in summary
yeah what do you think about I hate this
[ __ ] Bro one third Sam I hate it oh I
shouted them out that's why
one-third Sam makes these edits
one-third Sam those videos are [ __ ] up
I see them in Tick Tock just saying
right man
[Music]
I
don't like
oh yeah he is a he's a fan yeah right
[Applause]
made me uncomfy though to say
to say the least one
third Sam we love it
um server shares for worst moments as a
server this past summer a guy died in my
rest oh so are we trying to punt off
worst how many of us have worked in um
like restaurant service I mean I have
most of us yeah me and a b and I know
Sam has and Lena
and Ian have not been in service
and Zach
it's not a surprise yeah the most [ __ ]
that I think that means you guys are
privileged well I worked as a guitar
teacher
privileged job ever wow that must have
been really tough dude that's the most
oh my God I was a babysitter but
I I'm grateful for for yeah
you are
I was an H3 social media manager right
you've actually had the best life ever
yeah I'm pretty lucky so far your
professional life has been pretty cushy
yeah it has yes I mean service work
it is tough man in five years my dude
five years I really am so thankful for
it because I'll appreciate every job in
my life oh yeah you learn how to treat
people and you learn to be appreciative
for yourself and you learn how not to
treat people yeah
so I want my kids to work in the service
industry oh you're gonna throw them in
the gauntlet yeah I loved it I love the
free food especially oh you loved it
if you haven't I hated it too but I
usually co-workers it helps for sure
yeah cool I mean it can be fun right it
can be nice yeah the camaraderie and
stuff was fun but um yeah it sucks you
hate it every minute every minute I
think they're a little more hardcore in
Israel and also you guys get paid like
[ __ ] nothing yeah they don't even pay
you out do they wait just give you tips
because I couldn't remember what the tip
culture is and it's not very good it's
the same it's the same but also people
are rude
yeah like way way rude yeah yeah
Israelis are rude the managers are rude
everybody's rude it's just a whole
negativity experience so basically in
Israel you can you're guaranteed to make
minimum wage by law anything over that
and they take it all out also if there's
any mistakes somebody like accidentally
didn't charge enough somebody we're
gonna take it out of the tips
I don't know that's what they do they're
like what are you gonna do about it yeah
yeah it's crazy there dude it is crazy
um but I would say at least like the
service industry here if you're a young
person that's and like that's your best
option the money is like can be pretty
deep that's why I did it for five years
I mean yeah I will say that even though
I hated it like any
out of all of the sort of just
entry-level you know compared to like
just getting a job in retail or
something or or a fast food job or
whatever waiting is the best money
you're probably gonna make for like a no
you know other experience entry level
kind of job also I feel like in Israel
you kind of have to like also clean the
toilet oh my God you need to like clean
the floor you kind of like just the [ __ ]
person to do everything in a restaurant
[ __ ] that they make the busers mostly do
that here there's no busers in Israel oh
we don't have that well in any
restaurant where there's no busers I
suppose that would be the server as well
so we had to do that but we had Middle
Eastern owners so it's kind of the same
we went the relationship they would take
our tips oh really well they want to
take all of our tips but like you said
if we messed up or went over yeah
whatever it is it would equal out you
don't complain about it it's not easy to
get a job there
what is it you don't complain about it
um no it's illegal it's [ __ ] illegal
yeah I don't know go get another job I'm
kind of worried a lot of illegal stuff
goes on in restaurants yeah
the one night the drawer was short and
uh the owner's like all right all the
servers are splitting the cash of what
was short I was like okay that's fine
and then we find out that one of the
managers took money from the drawer to
to buy something supplies or something
and the owner's like oh well it was
short the other day so we're just gonna
keep it oh my God and it was like it was
even the same waiters that were here the
other night it makes no sense but yeah I
had I I mean the close thing I had is
managers
like general managers who would help
during the busy times and keep the keep
their own tips which is really [ __ ]
corny bro yeah I think I got away with a
lot less of that because I worked at
California Pizza Kitchen was a very
corporate restaurant right it's not like
a private owner or whatever so the
management was a little bit more not to
say that they didn't do you know
questionable things
um I mean one thing was like about once
a year they would do like a a sweep for
all of the back of the house people
um to make sure all of their uh papers
were
um
legal so to speak oh really yeah that
never happened in my work and what what
would always end up happening is they
would do one of those and then those
people would be fired because most of
them are uh
not legal undocumented uh undocumented
better that's the more up-to-date term
but then they'd be there the next day
um and suddenly their name was something
else they come back oh yeah I get hired
yeah they just they just rehire them as
a new as a new like Roberto is awesome
Quan today and Juan from now on that's
crazy we worked with a ton of
undocumented workers and those
[ __ ] were the hardest working
wild is something oh yeah yeah they
would work so hard and they partied so
[ __ ] hard yeah mad mad respect for
the back of the house and that's that's
part of why I never I tried to keep
complaining to minimum because
like as horrible as my job was it was
still not as bad it was the same as in
Israel because it's always like in the
kitchen that people watching the dishes
are the what you're describing Where in
Israel it's generally like Ethiopians oh
yeah right right
I had this co-worker he was a really
hard worker and and uh we hung out all
the time we were all friends at the
restaurant he come by my house all the
time one day turn on the news and he
went to jail for murdering his child oh
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] wild and
all he would work like he would just
brag about like how much he loves his
daughter and that's why he's able to
work seven days a week and oh that's so
sad show me it's happening no
I don't know like like how old was his
daughter
very young Lena do you know how young I
think like a year old or something he's
really young yeah it wasn't an
accidental it was extra straight murder
so that's what we all thought at first
but then when he finally spoke on TV he
was like uh
I made a mistake he's like yeah I just I
made a mistake
it was so nice maybe he was covering up
maybe for the mom or something I don't
know that's what a lot of us thought you
know we came back I don't know if it's
just because we all knew him we were
trying to like justified in our heads
but I'm I'm not sure it's
it is wild waiter waiting we'll do that
to a [ __ ] I think seven days a
week is too much bro yeah when a lot of
them work doubles like half the kitchen
staff at my restaurant they all worked
at another restaurant and they do a
morning shift and then they come and do
a night shift that's crazy was this like
your Guys restaurant the back of the
staff especially I think some of the
waiters too they're straight up smoking
like meth and heroin bro there was not
as much as that not in Israel but like
there's the undocumented workers and
some of the waiters will get on it
they're always smoking weed but I found
out they were smoking meth and heroin
dog they were partying like crazy uh
black tar it was mostly uh Coke that was
happening who could afford a car it'll
[ __ ] what that was happening in my
bar yeah meth and cult because Coke is
too expensive I don't think it was meth
but definitely Coke definitely I think
it's a Santa Cruz thing because at one
point like yeah Santa Cruz like a large
percentage of people I knew were smoking
black tar heroin that's [ __ ] nuts
no there was I was like you're all
smoking heroin like a bunch of people
that's not like a work drug there was a
yeah no I'm just gonna say there was not
at all who was on who was on heroin and
like
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh my God I need to breathe wait
I didn't they close Wiki fit or
something just the scoreboard the rating
yeah yeah
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
let me see if c-man replied oh my God
nothing so far sorry go ahead so no I'm
just saying yeah the hook of white would
always he was on heroin and he would
fall asleep and the tables would be like
where's our hookah oh my God it was
horrible and he had you know he was
dealing with fire too so it was a
dangerous combination yeah oh geez yeah
yeah I think I told the story but we had
a waiter at ours because everyone used
to get like
I don't know what the manager would
leave early and then it was all on us
who had no vested interest in the
business at all to close so we would be
eating like filet mignons wow and
drinking all the alcohol we wanted it
was really wait so somebody in the
kitchen was on your side yeah we're no
we're all together we were all on the
same team it's always like the kitchen
against everybody no because we they
would cook us food and we would hook
them up with drinks and [ __ ] and so it
was a it was a collaboration there but
at a certain point the owners were like
yo um we're missing like ten thousand
dollars worth of food
but actually what I was going to do
which wasn't very funny is that one of
the waiters got like a blackout drunk
and driving back home on the one which
if you don't know what the one is it's
like
very dark very windy road very dangerous
and he flipped his car and actually died
on the way home yeah it was crazy I
talked about this but yeah yeah you said
that they were drinking his memorial
yeah his family turned his memorial on
the side of the road where his [ __ ]
blood was on the road still they they
took a they had a kegger yeah I swear to
[ __ ] God it was so weird I know yeah
it is happening it happened and I I
guess the logic was like our boy liked
to drink so let's but I don't know at
the same time it's like um
yeah I think we all said like
different people mourn differently sure
yeah I mean you lost your child so but
yeah
someone said you let him drive I wasn't
there when it happened so don't blame me
I heard about it when when we were
living they got a lot of people that
were there felt really bad about it
though because everyone was trying to
figure out like how was he able to drive
home I think they said that he like held
his alcohol really good I don't know
just like everyone in Santa Cruz
everybody's always like drinking and
doing drugs yeah
like everyone who's ever gone to
accident drunk
they all say I'm a good drunk driver
um
yeah
drive angry he tried to hit and run he
hit a car and then he was trying to bail
good advice PNP no never mind I'm not
gonna go there either
back it up let's go that stuff so I was
going to watch this girl she was telling
um
a story of from the service industry
that maybe we could relate to
someone's bathroom
lights
and his wife
this past summer a guy died in my
restaurant's bathroom like choked and
died and his wife was like on her knees
screaming and crying and asking God why
and we didn't shut down the restaurant
we kept serving people and when they
were taking his body out in the body bag
I was taking tables 31's food to them
another time one of my co-workers had a
seizure and she had her head on one of
those metal shelves and so there was
blood everywhere and I was holding her
head until the ambulance got there and
after the ambulance got there I got in
trouble for not taking care of my tables
wow we had a work Christmas party okay
hold on where does she work Final
Destination Cafe I mean what the [ __ ]
going on there
so much violence bruh so I
so if I have settle on Edibles and then
the GM got extremely drunk and got up
and gave a speech about how much she
absolutely just [ __ ] hated everybody
one of the main people she talked about
was me and I had an old couple call
corporate complaining about me because I
said how are you guys and she was like
I'm not a man and literally cussed me
out and she was like I'm done talking to
you I'm not eating here anymore and
literally almost got me fired over
saying how are you guys when four Cooks
got a fist fight we had to shut down the
whole restaurant bro where do you work
yeah is this real more Cooks got in a
fist fight like an all-out brawl in the
kitchen trying to think this is I find
all this believable yeah by the way yeah
like one one of my best friends Almost
got stabbed with a butcher knife at the
restaurant Yeah by another Chef it was a
busboy who was friends with the chef a
busboy almost took a [ __ ] out
yep
[ __ ]
mold and all of our fridges and in
literally all of our food and our GM
told us that we didn't have the money to
replace it until literally just ignore
it and to never talk about it again this
old couple came in and before I could
introduce myself
um he laid out three one dollar bills on
the table and told me that those were my
strikes and did not mess up oh my God
you just kept taking wave like literally
for the most random things
Fireball and blacked out we had to go
through
cook around that's pretty I love serving
this past summer
that's pretty wild could you I don't
know could you possibly keep a
restaurant open if somebody died and
they're being taken out
I can't believe it I do believe it
really it's possible would you still eat
your food
depends how good it is
um I worked for a wedding venue as my
first job and there was a dead body
found in the river that the like the
wedding was taking place right in front
of a river and we found a body in the
river and the wedding kept going
that's awesome
yeah wait so so so there was a wedding
right below there's police and ambulance
and stuff taking their fishing the body
out and are y'all trying to just pretend
like it's not happening yeah well we
moved the wedding was just ending so we
were just like that's a body and we
moved everyone inside and then we called
the police to come out and oh good yeah
your priorities take care of the guests
always
by the way I just want to share some
donors uh Heather Marie thank you she
says Olivia a b Ila why just you three
please watch Julia Fox recent clock app
vid about bleach brows okay
um I don't go into clock a lot but when
I do I've been getting her tick tocks
Julia and she's kind of a legend I love
her oh you like the vibe yeah yeah
didn't know that
interesting
uh Chantelle says today's my 28th
birthday happy birthday a legend
Abigail says she worked at a casino for
eight years I'm sure you get all kinds
of crazy stories out of Casino I can
only imagine man yeah yeah that that's
got to be one of the craziest ones
you get everything there you get this
you get the alcohol you get the drugs
you get the food
I love how this chat Arrow navigating
thing doesn't work it's like great it's
just so cool YouTube
so cool I can't go to the list so cool I
literally can't go to the left do you
see that I mean what am I supposed to do
that's like stuff okay there we go
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Alex I want to hear the version of this
recapping AB Sizzler incident
it's like from the perspective of a
waiter is what I'm assuming
what's a b Sizzler incident when he
choked oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I forgot when it was happening
it's happening
right right right right right right yeah
been the back to Sizzler by the way
no you're muted
you're muted bro I shouldn't be uh yeah
no I have not been back but I drive by
it every day
shout out John manscuso 21 21 years is
yes 21 years alive with the drinking and
definitely don't drive 21 years what 21
year birthday oh 21.
um shout out to shy mccoren I have
coveted in these podcasts are keeping me
entertained God bless you thank you
thank you peace and love does somebody
know is this covid related yes yes it is
covet is covet related
um any other good restaurant stories
anyone has that they want to share
before we move on
I worked at Home Depot
um Mysterio woman says
I worked at Home Depot and someone fell
and died in front and everyone continued
as normal Jesus somebody fell and died
like off like one of the top shelves
because people get pretty high
Jesus
I mean I've told uh I told this story I
think actually I told it relatively
recently because I think it was when a b
choked but I had a customer once uh
choke on some uh tortilla chips like
badly and I had to give him the Heimlich
maneuver did it work and it worked did
he tip you he tipped me like five
percent no way it's always stuck with me
five percent straight up saved this
dude's life and he probably wanted to
give me the dog shits on his tip yeah
you should that wasn't your choice to
save me bro unbelievable
it was yeah it was it was like a it was
like a 40 bill or something and he left
me like two bucks three bucks oh my God
that is insane yeah it really blew my
mind
but you can say he tipped you five
percent so it's a full circle it's five
percent that means everything's that
nine percent
um Victoria says tell Ethan he's my
cousin no that's [ __ ] and that I
also found out through 23andMe that Ben
Shapiro is my cousin no no no we're not
related there's no shut up you and Benny
there's no shot I'm related to Ben
Shapiro we come from different we're
different worlds bro I I'm someday
oh wait I think you told me that this
wasn't true because isn't your your dad
was uh is not actually a client yeah
he's adopted or something
that's disappointing because my I I have
clients in my family tree my dad's mom
is Klein and that whole side of the
family is Klein so I always kind of
wondered if we were related dad's maiden
name is cats okay katzman no no
katzman's in the family what's weird is
um I'm more kind than you dude yeah yeah
I have no client like I have no client
lineage I'm the same I'm the same way I
have my last name's adopted as well it's
interesting yeah
foreign
what's interesting is my dad's
biological dad was like a big time movie
producer I never met him my dad never
[ __ ] knew him wait katzman yeah
Leonard batsman wait that it that's like
really big time yeah you want to know
that Alice or some [ __ ] I don't know
yeah but I've seen people try to say
that I'm like a um
uh
uh what's it called when I don't know
one of these baby like I got uh hooked
up because my grandpa is Leonard katzman
oh nepotism baby yeah nipple baby I've
seen it being said before wouldn't they
don't really know enough about me and
they see like if you go on Wikipedia now
it goes it says like Leonard katzman's
my grandpa which is weird but I never
[ __ ] met the guy my dad my dad never
met him once since [ __ ] he was like
two years old yeah and it's funny that
people go oh yeah you're a nepo baby I
don't I don't [ __ ] I never wait I
didn't know what it looks like I'm on
his Wikipedia and it talks about you on
his way it's getting weird I don't like
that it says Ethan Klein grandson is
like I don't even know what he looks
like bro Gary what my dad has a page
uh just like stage three yeah so so like
that's super weird you know yeah
and they lived in the same city is
really [ __ ] sad I think I talked
about it yeah he lived in Malibu he
basically like started a new family he
never and I showed no interest in my dad
is really sad the guy's a [ __ ] demon
for that
that's what happened with my dad as well
really yeah
I guess back then you could just like
Bail no my biological grandfather was a
huge piece of [ __ ] yeah oh this is what
he looks like I've never seen him before
this is the first time I've ever seen
what he looks like that's so crazy
that's my ACT that's my biological
Grandpa interesting crazy I've never
seen his face
yeah pretty good hairline
[ __ ] Grandpa
that's so weird ah this is trippy
beloved husband father grandfather not
to me [ __ ]
it shouldn't say absent father
grandfather that's so weird
so he gave so much and demanded so
little oh [ __ ] you
I mean there's nothing shittier than
what you did to my dad you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] there really is not as a father
of young kids uh imagine me walking out
of Theodore's life and never and then
showing no interest and living in the
same city living in the same city and
then as an adult your Dad tried to make
contact again and he just kind of like
dismissed him wow
my dad's mom
great lady yeah uh Grandma Eileen rest
in peace
when my dad had his first child my
sister
she called him and said just so you know
your son Gary just had his first child
if you want to call and he he ghosted
them
crazy yeah [ __ ] crazy yeah
what a monster bro a hole in your heart
damn
there he is
see mine tried to come back into my life
oh really yeah when yeah when actually
pretty recently I I was probably like 16
17. and so what you told them [ __ ] off
pretty much yeah and he'll still try and
why if he's making an effort I mean it's
not my business I'm not here to judge
because he really abandoned my my father
and my grandmother he just kind of took
off and left and um
he really isn't a good guy did he try to
make amends with your dad
um he wanted it more because he is like
an image thing I guess even though he he
went off and got another family and has
been buried multiple times and
it's it's very complex but he is a huge
piece of [ __ ] and I thought about giving
him another chance but it's just not
there well he's got to make amends with
your dad first yeah right got to skip
over the right skip over that he thinks
by sending a hundred dollar check here
and there that it's like making up for
it but um
maybe sent you a Rollie he's gonna need
more yeah he's gonna send bigger I mean
he has one if he did leave it to me you
know
we'll talk maybe we'll talk by the way
my grandpa father looks like a jewy ass
[ __ ] too boy he was Jewish
so it's all the way through that's where
I get to 99 from it's all the way baby
Leonard katzman my grandpa walked out on
my mom when she was two years old and
then like tried to make amends when he
was dying from cancer so
and then he just apologized to her for
like the last year of his life
just [ __ ] her up even more so dude
bro there's another shop I don't think
there's any greater sin than than uh
leaving your children
I think that's one of the worst things a
person can do in life period
as bad as murder honestly I mean really
it's so bad
quite a few terrible scenes you could do
but yeah that one specifically is so bad
you leaving your child
and that's that's just an abominable sin
that's just [ __ ] up bro so sad it's
not even illegal
well Gary's permitted to pop beach balls
now yeah I know Kaz Kaz gives my dad
permission
that's true smash that like button yeah
uh Victoria said I sent you a request on
23 me I can send a screenshot of your
23andMe profile yes send it to Dan I
don't [ __ ] believe we're cousins then
I think you have our
223 and me because you yeah yeah it was
that was oh my God that was like five
years ago now uh but the reason I know
that is because I recently wanted to
look at it again and I found it in an
email that you sent me with the login
yeah sure enough I have it right now I'm
logging in
Foo lock says I had an absent Jewish
grandfather too he was apparently a drug
runner in Mexico whoa
um it's kind of sick I guess back in the
day it seems to have happened a lot
where the dudes was just like I'm ready
to go start a new family it happened on
both my parents sides dude yeah mine
took off to New York and
he wanted to make something her life and
he never did
Amanda says this is happening to my son
his dad lives in the same town and never
reached out how can you do he moved into
town
didn't tell me or my son that's I'm so
sorry that poor child how can you do
that the kids deserve so much better
than that like that just doesn't exist
the kids deserve so much better man
so sad
really is I think people in general are
being are better parents you know what I
mean
like when I was a kid when my dad was
like you just beat the [ __ ] out of kids
you left them yeah you know what I mean
I was like nobody they're like in a
[ __ ] group grow up
I fought in a war damn it I thought I
was in the trenches now [ __ ] grow up
I was a cashier at Marshall's somebody
died in line waiting to check out and
people just walked around her to check
out I used are you serious
be true I mean maybe we really are just
like an ant Hive when you like it's
shocking right but at the end of the day
if somebody drops dead we all just go
business as usual like we were like well
you know the workers will come get her
and that's what the [ __ ] it is I've
accepted the fact that people just don't
care
We're Just Dance bro yeah honestly
Marshalls is a really long line too I
mean yeah they've got to get in and out
that's Marshall I need to get this
Calvin Klein I'm not trying to spend all
day in Marshalls
wait shahobi
shahab I made the Kobe person intro and
the child predator video
and I still can't believe you reacted to
it
um I vaguely remember it something that
we used or something we have reacted to
reacted to is what they're saying
it's the kidnapping
all the eyebrows
yeah that was my fave that was a big
meme yeah that was my fave you're a
legend bro that's funny we gotta show it
I don't think anyone was it was it the
dangers of social media
by the way thank you Bella Simmons for
the 50 gifted the gift of gifty
live chat privileges thank you Bella
you're a real one
um animus says my dad and my dad says I
left when I was born I had a new family
lives down the road for me and the first
time I saw him in 15 years is because I
was buying weed wow
that sucks dude that breaks my heart
it's just so [ __ ] up
yeah pull up uh did you link me Kobe I
did yeah I mean we did a lot of Kobe
person uh reaction videos
he was one of my fave pranksters back in
the day
yo and what was so good about these
videos reacting this one has 62 million
views like these were going Mega viral
and it made the reaction to it so much
juicier and then on Facebook they would
have even doubled that like 300 million
or some [ __ ] Jesus
but the best part was what hair watch
Person how easy is it for a pedophile to
pick up an underage child using social
media well today we're gonna find that
out I made a fake profile on Facebook
posting as a 15 year old boy with the
parents permission I friend requested
three girls ages 14 13 and 12 years old
I've been talking to these girls for the
last three or four days and today we're
supposed to meet up well we found a nice
video is shocking and something everyone
should see be sure to watch until the
end and use what we've learned in this
video to better educate your friends and
family hope you guys enjoyed it yeah my
joke was great what you've learned in
this video to be better at abducting
children the video yeah yeah
[Music]
oh that's a little inappropriate Kobe
let's catch and anyway those sexy kids
always trying to pick up
yeah man it just ain't like it used to
be for for reactions it's just not that
was such a crazy time on YouTube
and damn.com that was weird I don't know
what the [ __ ] all that was pranks the
first guy her name is yeah
that's so nostalgic I know I know it's a
good times man the content was just
insane
anyway
Leonard katzman
that's crazy that it says I'm his
grandson the goddamn
Wikipedia
but you could see how you would get the
wrong idea and think I was like some
nepo baby yeah you clicked that
what is nepo nepotism baby
like old hyper privileged you've got
your job to your family
you know and then here it says
okay it doesn't have him in mind at
least that's good
anyway it's three eight there's three H3
is a clown an Israeli clown
Enrique said you always like damn a lot
of people's dads left them that must
suck and then completely forgot my dad
left me
I'm the cool dad now
oh should we look at this is this good
um H3 gogoers auto complete yeah why was
H3 canceled well that's a long
you're gonna need a whole [ __ ]
article for that is Ela still with Ethan
that's a good question though I asked
that every day I guess if somebody
hasn't watched Us in years maybe they're
like
are they still together yeah maybe like
that
that's the second most asked question
though it's not by do you think
popularity I think so I think so
generally yeah
um how did Ethan Klein get rich uh what
do you mean yeah
Leonard katzman leopard I work you know
what I mean I work you know you see it
why oh yeah why does information you
blink weird that's a that's actually a
fair question of all of them does H3
have a disability I love that
our H3 and PewDiePie friends where do
you get that answer
what do you get if you type that
it's funny because some of these are
like just random ass wikipedias
answering nothing is this it's a quote
from you it says we do talk occasionally
we are definitely friendly I would
hesitate to call him a friend and what
is that from where is it pulling that
from uh dexterto article
you know what I think I realize what's
happening they looked at this and they
write [ __ ] articles
oh start with this and then they write
[ __ ] articles to the question oh my
God you're right
we all just learned a lesson in
journalism SEO does that surprise you
love
nope
I've done the same for many websites
what does ELA mean in Hebrew
Halo
there it is how much is Teddy fresh
worth I have no idea we don't know
Google that I need a I need my business
uh I don't think there is a number uh it
says between 50 to 100 million I'll take
that
foreign
[Applause]
pikecandy.com okay
for you that's reputable if anyone out
there is looking to buy Teddy fresh [ __ ]
that's up you just heard what it's worth
who owns Teddy fresh a net worth gorilla
also says the same thing it's just Teddy
fresh birthday
or this one is 50 to 150. can I use it
as an actual evaluation I wonder well it
says it on Google well what more do you
need
what is it called net worth gorilla
never misses yep
so hype gifted five subs thank you
Legend
how long has Dan worked for H3 we can
answer it's like five six uh if you
actually look it up what does it say
Olivia
since 1999. that's a long time I I guess
six right because steady fresh is five
years old and you started like around
the time yeah I think almost six years
probably uh we're at like five and a
half five and a half yeah to be specific
says dan started age three 1999 in a
public gym in Fort Lauderdale Florida
not accurate in any sense nope it's
actually about something else entirely
even you might say
Tito Thornton says can you tell my
girlfriend that I love her why can't you
tell your girlfriend you love me
it's not going to mean anything coming
for me communication is key tell her how
you feel
you feel that's awesome yo we're rich as
[ __ ] bro
that just made my weekend
150 million according to the gorilla
what race is Ela oh no Israeli human for
what rights is Eva that's interesting
I'm white 12 Italian I mean you're
definitely white passing I would say but
you are basically Middle Eastern I would
say you're you're uh medic right I mean
I have no idea I mean I know I have your
23andMe open right now I don't know what
it is you're from turkey turkey and
Libya that's what it says you're Middle
Eastern and and and it's made at least
they're in a race
uh generally no middle easterners are
considered Caucasian uh generally yeah
so yeah I mean white it it gets I don't
know it all gets tricky oh damn this is
yo bro dance word love is worth 10 mil I
[ __ ] knew that's so accurate I knew
it that's so and it should be and it
should be a lot more it should be a lot
more than that if we're being honest bro
I just Googled Dancewear four million
dollars a year
that's right that's right everybody
jacket off
whoa this shit's so accurate how old is
he think oh wait what causes Tourette's
why is it spelled like turrets turrets
machine guns turrets disease what causes
turrets disease bro I don't know what I
don't know man how old is Ethan that's
like the last question did Ethan shave
his eyebrows oh no [ __ ] look at a
picture idiot they're dumb because
they're dumb
let's Google some Isis videos
[Music]
next question it's not on the Elizabeth
says who does H3 have beef with again
long response very long response
so you got my 23 meal pin so do I have a
cousin is this person blowing smoke I do
not see in the notifications or the
messages anything so uh
not sure what's going on with that
that's what they uh the kids these days
call Cap your cap and okay you know your
middle eastern with North African and
Turkish Roots that's not white haha
but then somebody else said I'm Israeli
I'm white I don't know I think Israelis
are generally like white passing but I
mean I don't have no idea
so the question if you're asking are you
white you need to think what what would
the what would Tucker Carlson say
yeah yeah you're white Ela
but the thing is white is not a it's
that's a white is a social construct
it's not like an actual thing so when
they ask what race are you what is the
answer Mediterranean
being said yeah
because race is yeah that's a pretty
weird question I think they mean
nationality here's one how much does the
H3 crew make and of course they're
referencing H3 manufacturing group
that's us you know what finding out that
you guys are worth 100 Mil I'm gonna
need more than 13 an hour
anymore
you know let me see
or at least yeah sorry bro but it is
what it is man hey go back to Detroit
you get 13 for me bro
it's uh 15 an hour
that's pretty cool that LA's 15 an hour
that's pretty baller minimum wage I
think somebody else wouldn't they be
Jewish no Jewish is not race
ethnicity
again that's why like these things are
not very scientific it's kind of just
like a social construct because if you
ask some people you know at least
Ashkenazi Jews are definitely white
especially you know is Ethan white is
Ethan a white guy yeah a 99 Ashkenazi
but if you ask a Neo-Nazi he would
probably have a different answer yeah he
would say [ __ ] no he's not white exactly
Jews here is a channel that we
discovered called H3 Comcast
you guys want to see what it is yeah I
sure do oh it's great here's jacket off
so issue Comcast number 10 uh here it is
cause I'm coming hard come come come
come you put your head down like this
I'll give you fifty dollars if you want
to come Cameron how you doing you want
to come coming and then coming comes
come more and more coming they were
motivated to come come it's like the
balls were huge
I'm gonna come if you come
you really have to confirm why'd you
guys make this Logan Paul's really
coming up this channel why'd you do that
it's not just one go to the channel look
how many videos there are there's 12 of
them whoa
pretty impressive why are you doing the
amount of effort I don't like the number
six thumbnail but besides that really
good number six oh is that one bothering
you what about this one do you care
about what I look like at all
look at me in that Domino awful you look
like you're coming here this is number
one let's watch this oh yeah okay let's
watch that even the most viewed one so
let's see what's his Magnus for one guy
coming I'm having someone come because
they grinded it out of your mouth and
then you had to come come at the end I
like doing it with Hassan as well yeah
both come coming if he ever comes he
might have come people don't age that
well where I come come more come better
come more frequent coming down his
[ __ ] face like love for you to come
to we would love for you guys to come
come this is a weird channel oh why just
why why are you spending your time like
this
the amount of effort that went into this
is can we uh let's give him some
material I was gonna say can we all go
around and give him some fresh material
right now sure a banger episode this
one's for you come come come come
on down come oh come come come come come
come coming come coming go ahead
everybody come on come on uh come love
say it love
from everywhere around my room come on
dude come come come
come
come all right here come yeah go ahead
Ela and then I'll do mine come come come
come here ready this one's for you come
town or come pause whatever come in my
eyes come in my nose come in my ears
come on my stump fat stomach come in my
eyeballs come on come on my come come
shoot come on my [ __ ] and then on the
count of three can we all give them a
come at the same time sure like a home
like come like that yeah okay yeah I got
a little Mantra yeah you want to give us
a countdown can one two three
foreign
[Music]
well we haven't made it yet out of top
of the show just FYI I know I'm dying to
talk about Twitter
Ethan's Jordan Peterson I'll do this and
then we'll do it Ethan Jordan Pearson
impression is scary good
oh my God
Fable of the Three Bears is really oh
this is a lot
and it's like she and it's like she went
in there to taste the porridge
but instead
she found a big swamp and it was Shrek
and Donkey
foreign
[Laughter]
we have a great story about Ian too
imploding the whole Kanye fandom
bathroom but let's do ela's uh Twitter
and then we'll do uh Ian Kanye implosion
oh you also have a PowerPoint Olivia
well we're an hour and a half in so um
also I want to do the crazy chemical
peel too I love that one
well we better slam baby what's the
PowerPoint it's a look book so it's not
like meme history there's no there's no
it's all you yeah there's no text just
there's just a label of all your looks
all your slaves from the years
I like that
it was talked about
uh last week when we were last Friday it
was like wow you have really changed
yourself so many times let's take a look
at it I mean as he lived in the bathroom
um start slideshow all right so Ethan
Klein lookbook starting of course as the
bronze God
before four before four there was before
five before five there was three before
threes before two
but first new Ethan ethoot just dropped
[Laughter]
looking good buddy
you look like a [ __ ] snack looked
like a Thanksgiving turkey
his Royal Majesty I forgot about that
one this was one we did for uh we're
making fun of Psychics
the Bobby Finn Bobby like Bobby thin
Ross I love that one these names were
all made up by Olivia just wait right
that's a been Love's profile picture
yeah that is me actually right A lot of
people think that that is love because
that's been his icon on his reply guy
account oh it's this again yeah it's the
right one atrial Contacts baby yeah I'm
still text him I see that face in my
head
um this right this was a good one I
enjoyed this and you know who you know
who paid for this Ryan [ __ ] Kavanaugh
we were promoting one of his movies what
oh my God it was saw wasn't it no it was
something wait it was so it was the one
with Zach Galifianakis where
they're like what would you build if you
had all the money in the world master
Mastermind yeah masterminds that was a
um that was a a relativity yeah it was
relativity
yeah it was Zach Galifianakis
I thought it was I guess that was a
different one that was one of the
fattest deals we ever got actually I
remember so I was the second bait Nation
yeah yeah the masterminds my
relativities well distributed by
relativity media I see that under it's
on their websites on relativity's
website oh well there you go idiot
[ __ ] loser
yeah good marketing bro you paid my ass
like I don't remember dude I think we
got like 75 000 Jesus too much wine I
don't even remember that movie dude it
was horrible I never even watched it
they sent me a screeners I'm not
watching this [ __ ]
I said I'll make the [ __ ] video I
don't watching it as with the fattest
deal we ever got jeez we bought a drone
with it and then the cops got us
immediately said you can't fly that I
said okay whatever
I'm Gonna Keep the Drone it's awesome
uh the Full Beat oh my God is that the
gamer gunk no this was the uh beautiful
challenge or what was it don't judge me
challenge
the conservatives favorite right
I'm still not a hundred percent on the
context of this one was it dude wipes or
was it no dude wipes was at a different
location I think
yeah I'm not sure but
um looking good high and tight
I've watched since Israel
him
you know who it is Ken Bone yeah her
look at her the the right slide yeah I
love it so much everything it's
everything
he's so fast this was a fun shirt I
remember when we made this video a lot
of the like fans were like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] content why are you
making this [ __ ] really I love that
video I did too but there was a time
when we were doing like edgy reaction
comedy and then we started posting
videos and then this was this was not
edgy enough you're like bro this is
[ __ ] lame content H3 is dead like
comments like that
dude in that video it's so hard for me
to watch the part where they're sawing
their shirt off you I was like oh my God
I was getting so antsy I don't even get
cut for sure but just to tell you like
this was so [ __ ] thick it wasn't even
close to me when they were signed
Sunday morning
um the CEO sure let's see that that's
one of my favorites this is the one we
did with Jesse uh yep yeah nice guy fun
video we did with him that edit is so
sick oh yeah yeah he did it when you
walk walk by all the restaurants
everyone's checking me out yeah yeah I
like that
obviously the viral uniform yeah
the Elis husband we also shot this with
Jesse didn't we yeah that's part of the
same video yeah the four looks you need
this summer yeah right
the sister special
uh yeah that was fun I love the
commitment you know Uncle says the Unk
the unk
the contacts are working yeah I love
that and the shaved eyebrow do you know
how hard it was to get those contacts in
y'all oh yeah I remember you were
struggling for a while because I I don't
wear content or worn contact oh yeah
that's tough this is so weird to put
something in your eye it was so weird
the videos that I pulled the two on the
side from
um you kept with your acrylics going
like this like telling the camera no no
no and is it just because you loved the
way the nail felt I think I was just
vibing I don't know I don't know I loved
it it's not right
that's got to be one of the best that
one was insane crazy
that one was so good holy [ __ ] it
doesn't even look like me
oh yeah forgot about that one the curl
cap what was the context of this one
dude I had the same question when she
pulled this up the other day I was like
what the [ __ ] was even happening here
yeah what is this from I don't know
there was just an extra episode of
Frenemies though it was it was funny
because it was the infamous Jeff efforts
yeah before you were interviewing Scott
that's what I looked like yeah no or it
was the same week maybe it was in the
aftermath
we had our big that was like a big
friendly moment we were like exploding
on the internet at the time that's what
I looked like oh you know what you know
what I'm mistaken I'm mistaken I was
sworn it must have been the same week it
was yeah the responding to David I don't
like the way my hairline looks
oh you're talking about your actual
hairline yeah I thought you were just
joking I'm not kidding I don't ever care
about my hairline
um
the Mr Green this one was really good
that was crazy so good so good
I do miss all the dress up I'll be
honest these were so fun to do the
Beetlejuice that one was amazing
you should keep dressing yes I feel like
it's so fun yeah it's nothing oh we did
it with um you know Halloween
pretty [ __ ] expensive and time
consuming it's a little it's a little
bit hard to justify when I'm not getting
like five million views per episode
right yeah that's true which was nice
the budget on that show was pretty much
we could have ridden Bezos stuff we
could have gone I could have gone to
space with tradition if we were still
doing Frenemies we'd be on Origin blue
going to space together I swear to God
that's the budget
yeah you shaved your head right after
the Jeff wittick interview Fallout and
you were like should I just shave it and
then you did
and then you had the curl cap
the powder puff of course who could
forget
a Drizzy special that one is so funny
the boy in blue
this was I think that yeah this was the
Oliver tree yes yeah little blue boy the
JF
K the Hefe my name Jeff
that's a Vibe and of course the newest
that's just the Ethan climb oh that's
just me being me
[Applause]
okay cool there you go slay thin what
will she do next you'll have to watch to
find out that was fun actually that was
a nice little walk down memory lane yeah
Angel Angelina says I worked at a very
big retail company and made me stand
outside during covet counting customers
while I was miscarrying with no break
Jesus Christ
what what
the [ __ ] did I just read
oh no no let me read that again let me
read that
I'm in Brazil I'm considering what I'm
considered white in the US I'd be
considered George Zimmerman I'd be
considered being murdered by George
Zimmerman right I see what you mean yeah
you're saying people get pretty
dark-skinned in Brazil there's like a
whole cast there
I'm assuming
it won't let me go to the left guys
let me go to the left I don't know what
the [ __ ] to say
God damn this thing are you just trying
to see that message again yeah yeah I
got it for you
I worked at a very big retail company
they made me stand outside during covet
counting customers while I was
miscarrying
no breaks
how does that uh
I I I don't know a lot about miscarrying
um I know that sometimes orally you can
take a pill if it's
early enough and maybe you're I I'm not
super informed on how mobile you can be
while that is happening you definitely
need a break that's all yeah it weren't
a break yeah I'm probably not excuse me
standing outside having a miscarriage
shut the get outside and count
thank you by the way to Elaine Christian
for the 50 gifts
thank you to prolapsed penguin nice to
see you five gifted we have lots of new
people folks I thought comedy was alive
and well yeah well you thought wrong
[ __ ] ass ninja hater of the show enemy
of the show Ninja
dumbass idiot he is love thanks I'm glad
you took my side against him of course
all right so let's get into
um Ila's uh Twitter drama I have to pee
now too oh
do that to me
I'll be right back after you read all
the comments
and Donald's
dry there's lots of there's still lots
of stuff
uh I'm seeing a few people ask in the
chat about uh Bradley
um so I guess I can address that because
yeah I think originally when we talked
about it we had said that he was going
to be here today yeah yeah but um the a
scheduling thing came up last week and
so it is Zach been confirmed uh yes it
is uh December 2nd okay which is a
Friday I just wasn't sure if that was
confirmed confirmed but yet uh December
2nd another Friday episode so
Ela will be here and uh I will it's
gonna be a fun one we're planning some
stuff for Mr Mr Martin I think it's
going to be pretty entertaining
I've been exercising
and I feel fit for this interview really
oh I see
what what kind of exercising
yep you have like a trainer yeah yeah
and it's twice a week and every time
[ __ ] kills me and then I'm sore pretty
much until the next time sure why that
means it's working and is it actually
the reason I started is because I was
having terrible back pain
and I was like is something wrong with
my back so I went to finally see a
doctor and he was like no it's just
muscle you just need to work on your
muscle basically because I was showing
him where it hurts and he was like
that's a very typical just weak muscles
sure
um so I was like I just have to do it
because I kept putting it off it's so
hard to find the time
um and since I started my back actually
doesn't hurt which is crazy yep it's
like crazy yep I uh I had a similar
thing mine was induced because uh years
ago I was in within like a period of uh
I want to say it was like three or four
months apart I got in rear-ended really
severely uh in my car twice what yeah
like back to back it was both times
sitting at red lights and somebody just
plowed into me and so I had really a bad
back pain after that and I thought it
was just going to be like that for life
and yeah they instructed me the same
thing as like uh working out those
muscles will probably help a lot and
they were right and I still struggle
with it a little bit but generally yeah
if you work on your core muscles and
everything it can severely reduce the
pain I mean I it shouldn't be like so
surprising to me but but I'm so
surprised by it because I don't know
especially with the boys having to pick
them up and sure put them down pick them
up put them down it's been like some
days my back was just like I couldn't do
anything and now it's just gone and and
Bruce has been giving us a really hard
time lately at nights he's not sleeping
through the night so it's a lot of
picking him up putting him back and
normally that would have like killed me
sure on my back and now I'm fine
so
give it up give it up yeah
you're giving me like a electric chair
with that hat or something are you sure
I just walked over and saw your ass like
something's going on with that hat I
like that you like the electric chair
yeah okay
hardcore
all right so Ela
dude this is crazy I feel like this is a
crazy this is kind of insane let's just
start how do you think shut the [ __ ] up
Jordan I'm sick of your idiot ass
Rat Hole
um you know what you know what Jordan
Pearson calls um
800 DPI I'm not gonna say it I'm not
going to say it what the [ __ ] was that
my [ __ ] yeah what is that I don't
recognize that who's that hold on
800 yeah where the [ __ ] are you watching
hold on hold on hold on
I think it's your mouse yeah why is your
mouse 200 to DPI what the heck Dan if I
never pressed this button I've never
pressed this button to change the DPI on
the mouse it has this plus and minus the
wrist of your mouth yes no 100 DPI
sounds like a Halo kill let's [ __ ]
see it does yeah
I was like what is the sound bite I
thought it was Zach
800 TV there's 200 DPI what the [ __ ] so
I'm gonna pull that now and just create
it people are saying Dan's mouse's voice
is hot
really by the way thank you to so hey
but for another 20 gifted you legendary
follow up on the red post combo with my
friend the Elon Stan I sent him the link
and he said we're all lib idiots sent a
pic of Ethan he said Ethan can't run a
mile under 23 minutes
[Music]
yeah I was just I wanted to be confident
I think I could do that yeah I'm pretty
sure you can yeah I could do that I
think you could just walk okay yeah
walking fast you'd have to walk fast
yeah which you know not always easy
crew member Dennis Mouse I've seen more
people Dan's mouse's voice is hot what
the [ __ ] hit it again
800 DPI yeah it's sort of like it's got
that light yeah it's kind of an accent I
don't think he's a native English three
thousand two hundred
yeah seems to have some kind of
Scandinavian accent
800 DPI the today's his DPI is not
native yeah yeah it's probably because
some dude on Fiverr that they made
just a follow-up post oh I just read
that all right let's do so let's get
into this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah so
I like many people are enjoying watching
Twitter
implode my favorite
um yesterday it was really popping off
there was this news because Elon offered
this ultimatum
I think this is it here he called it
Twitter
2.0 here's a text message of the email
must set to Twitter staff overnight
those who don't commit to being
extremely hardcore by 5 PM ET today must
leave the company now again
this is insane because
I said this before
with Tesla and SpaceX he's able to
exploit workers because they're
passionate about the project Twitter is
not the same yeah you're a spot on these
are engineers and they want to be
[ __ ] paid and they want good working
additions and if you don't give it to
them they'll easily get it somewhere
else and by the way he should not have
done that even with Tesla and SpaceX
yeah it just tell us what a shitty
employee clearly was doing that thank
you Lena oh my God you brushed candy I
wanna I felt like I needed a little bit
of sugar you need a little hit to not
start yawning on the show
because I don't want to disrespect our
beautiful audience
oh respectful Queen so respectful Queen
right there and so basically he gave
this ultimatum he says going forward to
build a breakthrough Twitter 2.0 and
succeeded and increasingly competitive
world we will need to be extremely
hardcore this means working long hours
at high intensity only exceptional
performance will constitute a passing
grade I'm already out I didn't even put
this in writing I know and there's so
many leaks like I love how everything
just goes public immediately can you
imagine
Twitter will also be much more
engineering driven design and product
management will still be very important
and report to me but those uh writing
great cards will constitute the majority
of our team and have the greatest way I
love that he's like hey yeah so all you
[ __ ] losers by the way take a back
seat yeah
why would you even say that like why are
you going on your way to diss the other
departments
at it's heart Twitter is a software and
server company and I think this makes
sense if you are sure that you want to
be part of the new Twitter please click
yes on the link below
anyone who has not clicked yes by 5 pm
tomorrow Thursday will receive three
months of severance and be fired
whatever City you make thank you for
your efforts to make Twitter successful
so the only right answer to this as an
employee is to not click the link in my
opinion three months Severance yeah
hello so it was reported that it they
started the day with 2 000 employees and
it was reported I guess it's been
amended but what I heard is that they
ended the day
with like between two and three hundred
they lost like nine percent of their
Workforce no it's definitely more than
that more well the latest updates I'm
seeing is about 1200 employees quit
yesterday wow so that's like 60 of their
Workforce yeah well it's it was because
they've already he immediately fired
half the staff at Twitter like a few
weeks ago when it came in and then has
been publicly firing random employees
that would criticize him on Twitter yeah
over the last few weeks and then this
uh ultimatum that he gave yesterday it
I've seen various estimates it sounds
like about a half of the remaining
people quit again which I'm seeing
estimated around 1200 so it sounds like
there's probably about a thousand
employees left at the company whereas
they started when he came in it was like
it was 9000 or something like that so A
Thousand yeah wow so we're we're way
down 9 000 employees well that what do
you mean why I mean Twitter I don't know
it's running sounds like you have the
same opinion as Elon that's what he was
saying I mean I mean I I don't know I
don't know much about like the internet
but 9 000 employees were on Twitter I
mean well who's moderating all the
content usually every person in the
world is on Twitter so 14 7 500 just
seven so we're talking about moderating
team and everything
their revenue comes from ads so I'm sure
a huge like ad sales department and then
all the administrative people HR with a
moderating team that that makes sense
yeah
hundreds of millions per year on
Innovation it says on their like end of
the year Innovation is Twitter yeah well
they could they were like they didn't
even add an edit button we went from 128
characters to 2
about 100 million on Intervention that's
been the biggest Innovation with the
[ __ ] invention literally 300 million
dollars a couple years ago they spent on
one year
pushing us forward in the future uh
Chelsea by the way thank you for the 10
gifted you absolute Queen I sent Abe a
message on Discord earlier but I am
texting with my friend who got laid off
from Boulder office he has some
interesting information I don't know
what that what is Boulder office the
boulder office of Twitter oh let's get
him on the line we need it
[Applause]
chill Ninja
yeah so um excuse me but the reports
were super interesting it was like
people were getting locked out
eventually so many people left that they
shut they revoked badge access and they
shut down all the offices and people
were getting [ __ ] inside the office
Elon had to beg someone to come back to
open the doors for them I don't know if
that was a joke or if that was real I
think it was real I think it was real
too
from 15 minutes ago from New York Times
Twitter had 7 500 full-time employees at
the end of October was dropped to about
3 700 after Mass layoffs the employee
number are likely to remain fluid as the
dust settles on the exits with confusion
abounding over who is keeping a tally of
workers running other workplace systems
they don't even know yeah it's like they
literally don't know how many people
working they don't even have someone
keep like counting they fired HR
uh it's a free-for-all there it's like a
battle royale yeah
yeah who's even on payroll there's gonna
be so many like uh Milton from Office
Space situations well and they don't
even know because yes guess who else
they lost I guess their whole payroll
department quit so there isn't even
anybody in payroll and so yeah the other
thing that's interesting are they going
to run the next payroll dude deadlines
you have to I just wanted my stapler
yeah
well so what's interesting there's been
a lot of whole departments leaving there
was like the server side some really
critical infrastructure the whole team
left yeah
and so
here's some of the uh
here's some of the excerpts here a
number of Engineers tending to multiple
critical systems have been reduced to
two one or even zero according to people
familiar with the situation
who spoke on the condition of uh
anonymity of fear of retaliation Elon
retaliating never
the crisis came in response to an
ultimatum we read that I know of six
critical systems like serving tweet
level of critical which no longer have
any Engineers a former employee said
there's no longer even a skeleton crew
Manning the system
it will continue to Coast until it runs
into something and then it will stop
according to the New York Times
employees at Twitter
just began hanging up as Elon Musk was
talking during a video conference call
today wow apparently deciding to quit
and take the severance that's awesome
I mean yeah three months is pretty
generous I would totally take that yeah
good luck getting that with no payroll
no who's cutting the checks I had the
same thing they're not going to get it
they're not gonna get it now they're
gonna get well they might get it when a
lawsuit inevitably happens but I don't
think they're getting paid until they
didn't think about that I think he's
just doing that for PR so that
everyone's not mad at him but I don't
think any of those people are getting
Severance damn he just wait dude he's
gonna get sued yeah he's oh yeah bet
your ass you can get sued let's not talk
about how much wrongful termination how
much uh Severance not being paid and you
know this is in California right the
labor laws here is it in LA no it's in
San Francisco the labor laws in San
Francisco are insane I'm sure too I'm
familiar with LA because that's where
we're here
oh
yes as of six minutes ago Andrew Tate is
back on Twitter
let's [ __ ] go speeches free again
baby speech wait I'm gonna I'm gonna
hang up on Tick Tock he's letting
everyone back on Twitter but me and me
now no jumper tweeted that out it as an
announcement for Jordan Peterson and
Andrew Tate are now back on Twitter what
about me what the [ __ ] did I do
I think you'll get banned honestly
unbanned
maybe I don't know I think he's a butt
hurt your account's still suspended so
as of right now I have I haven't still
suspended
I have a pretty compelling argument
that this was a direct retaliation
against me and Ila because he's actually
butt hurt that we were goofy because
let me play it out let me play it out
Dan
don't don't poo poo just listen to me
Andrew Tates back on Twitter
yes just what the world needed
no
so if and if so if Jordan Peterson
starts being like
um Elliot page is Elliott pages
destroying
little girl's butting breasts starts
going like that what's good is nothing
gonna happen
I will presume not because that's what
he got banned for and that and now he's
unbanned so
I don't think that that's
against the rules anymore the mob is
this real the mob wait is this real
yes yes that's real oh
by the way remember Jordan could have
just erased that tweet and got back any
time
no
Andrew Mastery is a funny thing
it's almost as if on a long enough time
scale losing simply isn't an option okay
bro this was your grand scheme right
such as all part of the plan yeah bro
girl
this was all part of my master plan
shut up idiot
quartering oh yeah oh is he is he oh
he's he's let's see quartering he's
pissing oh he's ha I mean okay yeah it
is funny that was the point he likes the
joke it's a little IQ inbred loser
that's what I that's why I agree I mean
yeah I also think it's funny so
I'm glad you're like the joke I made
that was the pull point
right like right dude Jordan Peterson
I'm looking at his Twitter right now he
must have been going through massive
withdrawals from Twitter because he's
fully on a tweet Bender right now
10 times it was you're not familiar
Jordan Peterson tweets like that every
day he is so unwell oh my God he tweets
like 100 times a day he's tweeted so
much in the past it's the next level he
does that every day and you wonder this
is one of the great intellectual leaders
he he sees me he's unhinged
he posted seven Tweets in a matter of
like five minutes it's like he's doing
no not November yeah
uh what a [ __ ] show oh my God
um I'm counting right now I'm at 23
tweets
from today
like in the last like hour less uh
within four hours that's status quo for
him I'm serious he is yeah no that
sounds about right he's the most psycho
Tweeter maybe that I'm aware of
yeah so anyway
um
let's see
oh yeah and then okay so more reports
are coming out Twitter just alerted
employees that affected immediately all
offices are temporarily closed and badge
X is suspended
apparently because they were afraid of
of uh disgruntled employees trying to
sabotage or steal Secrets or something I
don't know
um
Elon posted this which actually I was
going through the replies so all last
night everything was just rest in peace
Twitter Twitter's down everyone's just
saying their prayers it was like there's
nobody left it's just coasting along
like on autopilot until it hits the damn
side of the wall or something
and um check this out how do you make a
small fortune in social media start out
with a large one okay so I read the
quote tweets this is a hundred percent
like I didn't see one supportively I
hate you we all hate you you [ __ ]
prick you will never know love you'll
never really truly [ __ ] know if
anyone loves you only Toadies and psycho
fans no love and you deserve it you
heartless [ __ ] good choke on your
money I was like oh my God and that has
500 likes too I was like oh [ __ ] wow
that's pretty [ __ ] since we're being
sincere I just want to say that was
pretty shitty of you to buy something
millions of people love and even rely on
for their lives and livelihood and then
set it on fire to mute yourself I
actually thought that was a good point
yeah
that is what's happening yeah
but I was given a choice where I could
either be remembered as a Visionary who
took a man to Mars or a thin-skinned and
complicated universally loaded ship bag
there's been 44 billion dollars to
destroy Twitter I think I go a different
way than you yeah that's well said
I mean they're all just bad bad bad bad
you lost 44 billion and no one likes you
let that sink in
what a mistake he did when he walked in
with that sink dude like do you not know
how memes work
oh my God but like in fact people still
like him after this but like this is
meme
like if he he is to memes what cucks are
in the right ring world too betas or
whatever the [ __ ] I mean
bad news sir we had surprisingly few
takers on our offer to work twice as
hard as the same pay on a site that
caters exclusively to neo-nazis damn who
could have seen this coming
there's a bit of Hitler in everyone
that's true that's a fair point
um
so
as this is all going on
yeah meanwhile actually Twitter
headquarters in San Francisco
this was even just straight
um being projected onto the building
Elon Musk
pressurized privileged Petty racist
megalomaniac
uh worthless billionaire
here let me I don't think that's gonna
get claimed but
a bankruptcy baby play it anyways yeah
you get the idea Supreme parasite
petulant they're they're really playing
with the apartheid profiteer they're
having a lot of fun there with the word
play
that was just on the building
it was a free-for-all
um thank you silken cookies listening to
Umi bee Bobby I'm realizing how many
hilarious gifts this show has blessed us
with party till I die yeah love y'all
shout out to my husband thank you God
bless you listen to that yeah that's
funny I haven't jammed to this in a
while she claimed our [ __ ] that's why
yeah the second time the party till I
die one I think slip by but
so as all this is going on
and they're saying you missed the
funniest one space Karen space Karen
I like that
that's a nice that's a nice thing
so okay now this was Ela on her Twitter
account okay so last night we were home
just on our phones and I was like all
consuming this [ __ ] loving it and I was
like hey I never tweet this is the time
to tweet twitter is dying yeah and so I
was like Ethan what should I say and
then we're like
um you know Twitter went downhill since
Ethan was bad that was the first one
this has been downhill ever since yeah
band Ethan and which is true actually
that is actually true right and then we
both directly related this is so fun
Ethan what else do you want to tweet and
I you know first of all this was all Ela
tweeting yes and we thought it would be
fun just to taunt Elon and Twitter
support because nobody's there nobody's
there yeah dude you know nobody's there
like let's be [ __ ] real there's
nobody checking Twitter support
the office is closed and this is how I
know that Elon is such a petty little
[ __ ] [ __ ] who's doing this at
retaliation I tagged him he saw this in
his verified mentions
and by the way he banned it for
impersonation there's no first of all
this is igla's account
there's no it's just a picture of me
there's no evidence that this is a
um impersonation going on here also
really there's not this is a joke
[ __ ] joke what happened to Comedy
it's comedy it's literally just a joke I
didn't know this isn't even what um
this isn't even what bandivating is this
is her account I didn't make a new
account you know what I mean yeah and
I'm not even well I'm not trying to
pretend to be Elon Musk or to be Ethan
Klein dude which I may have wanted to
but it wasn't even possible you can't
change your name and by the way yeah I
tried to chat we tried to change it to
Elon Musk that'd be the funniest but
um
um and you know there's no you know
there's nobody there this she got
permanently banned for this [ __ ] Post
Yeah in an hour
it also it was at night you're telling
me that this is their top priority while
everybody's leaving the company
it's not it's like not even like an
urgent issue it's like one stupid and it
wasn't like spam tweeting it was just
this it's just a picture of me smiling
it was no reason there were no red flags
there's literally like
first of all I'm not surprised we're
banned no I'm not surprised we were
laughing the whole time having like a
really great time but this is so dumb it
just gave me right to court like all
these idiots go oh he's complaining
about getting I'm not complaining about
getting banned I think it's funny that
it happened obviously there was an
attempt in like the dumbest way possible
get banned to bait Elon and he actually
took the bait it had to be him I told
Ethan like this is fine with me let's
burn this account I totally expected
this dude and like this isn't an urgent
issue this isn't like a flagrant
violation the building is on fire and
this is the top priority within hours
also we're a married couple I'm a
verified influencer this is my husband
like I'm not wow this is so dangerous
it's not we gotta ban this account yeah
so the Tweet said this is Ethan you
[ __ ] loser at Elon Musk at Twitter
sport I'm bandwidding they'll stop me
now [ __ ] ass loser the joke was that
nobody's there right and but elon's
there
of course he is uh this app's been
downhill and then I did this one too
suck my dick Elon Musk
and tagged him and then this one footage
a footage of Twitter employees stripping
utilities from abandoned office I
thought that one was funny
pretty good thank you and then um and
then either got he either got uh
suspended
It's gotta be him and it's not even
really in violation like usually it's
not what is the violation
yeah now now the reason I do think it's
him is also because look at what he
tweeted today where he's like hate
speech something where was it
uh can you go to his Twitter because I'm
not logged in here it's in the dock um
number eight okay uh he tweeted oh yeah
this was great but this ain't the next
day I mean the same day yeah today today
he tweeted us today he says Kathy
Griffin we go out we're in the first
part okay new Twitter policy is freedom
of speech but not freedom of reach it's
like okay well really Innovative bro
this is
we reached uh well she finished but this
this tweet is negate he says negative
hate tweets will be Max D boosted and
demonetized oh the demonetized so no ads
or other Revenue to Twitter
you won't find the Tweet unless you
specifically seek it out which is no
different from the rest of the internet
then he follows up by saying Kathy
Griffin who was reported alongside me
for being banned by Elon Musk Jordan
Peterson known Tran a transphobe I don't
know the [ __ ] Babylon B is or if that's
a joke I don't know what that is Babylon
B is uh what do you call it it's like
the onion for conservatives it's like
the onion but not funny basically okay
okay and trumpets has not been made yet
okay but
um and Andrew Tate was led on but my
account is mysteriously uh still
permanently banned and then this morning
Ela got permanently banned
you can't even really say that we were
that I was
Evan evading it was Eli of course it's
arbitrary yeah it's it's just it was
literally a joke
it sounds like he's considering mine
hate tweets
how was yours I hate tweet I hate
Twitter we said minority it's like a
hate tweet would be about like a yeah no
good group yeah you are you are singling
out a protected group billionaires who
own Twitter yeah
also just as a side note he spelled
Kathy wrong and also Jordan yeah
right oh so he's a bad speller too
Thor Dan he tried to spell it out oh I
hate him for that year long ma is
probably a better speller my favorite
person is
new new policy
we're going to Shadow ban hate speech
yeah that is
quite literally
the number one complaint of
conservatives
about Twitter before he bought it that
it that is like he
specifically narrowed in on the exact
thing that they were supposedly also
pissed off about I'm going to suppress
hate speech on Twitter new policy yeah
that's interesting yeah I think he's
like I'm gonna but somehow they're all
buying it like it's some weird
psychology game that he played on some
of them are actually starting to turn on
him as you'll see the next link uh
because there there was another uh
development about who's not getting
unbanned and they're not happy about it
oh yeah yeah yeah but but like it's hard
I feel like with almost certainty that
he is
specifically went out of his way to ban
Ela and not on Banos it's like straight
up a grudge I think it has to be
to be crashing last night
and there was so much going on and they
went out of the way to abandon my
account the officers were locked down
and it wasn't bad it wasn't like I was
at 3am I wasn't messing with like
insulin you know there wasn't like some
big problem with what I tweeted except
Elon Musk but you got a love that
actually
we were able via Twitter to actually
[ __ ] get under this this this loser
ass
[ __ ] shitty meme sink the sink let
this sink in Elon I got under your skin
you [ __ ]
yeah
got it
but we'll see maybe maybe my account
will come back and then we'll be cool
again
um we'll be best buds yeah we'll be a
friend of the show you know I must use
my best friend I love him um so
basically see people I've seen multiple
people say your account is unbanned
check again I I don't know if it's like
mine was just
they're saying Ethan's it says your
account is permanently suspended yeah I
don't think so I think dude
I think they're getting I think they're
getting uh they're getting tricked by
the uh yeah my account is permanently
banned and I doubt I will ever get it
back yeah mine too
if yours permanently banned then that's
some [ __ ] [ __ ] permanently bad oh
it does say that it does look yeah so so
it just updated and now it says that
yo that's [ __ ] retaliation screenshot
dude I have no doubt in my mind none
none
that's awesome
oh that's awesome
so there it is
um we showed them my appeal that I oh
yeah I'll pull that up so of course uh
Ela appeal he was in that same album
with the illa tweets
what number is it uh I think it was
eight uh let me look again
uh no I'm sorry um six
so um Ela of course rightfully um
appealed it as did I I peeled mine I
said yo parody was in the header and the
[ __ ] description it was uh people it
was a little different in town and then
Ela rightfully appealed it she said
they say uh tell us the problem you're
having and we'll tell him we'll I wrote
I posted a joke that my husband was
tweeting as me last night it was comedy
that's at its finest in my honest
opinion and it says comedy is now legal
on Twitter can I have my account back
I'm a verified influencer Ela Klein look
it up is anyone here hi Elon by the way
if you're the only person left want to
slide in my DMs I'm a hot male
holy [ __ ] thank you they said
oh my God yeah so he's actually spite
Banning people it's pretty crazy
this guy's actually spending his day
spite Banning people on Twitter holy
[ __ ] comedy is late and they did he
actually tweeted out comedy is legal
again on Twitter
like oh my God
and he's the most pure this is the most
punitive and insane Twitter has ever
been yeah yeah like by far this would
never happen on Twitter I mean he's
explicitly saying that
we're gonna Shadow ban you if if your
Tweet is negative yeah that's what I'm
saying that tweet from today
that's what he's saying super crazy yeah
this is what Ela says same as mine your
account is permanently suspended yeah
it's like you're telling me that I'm
yeah I'm ban evading on this verified
user's account with a million followers
and you're permanently gonna permanently
ban that one okay got it I've
essentially been banned from Twitter
like usually on that kind of thing
there's oversight there's like we got to
make sure we're in the right decision
it's clearly Elon
so anyway continuing on he States and
this is where the right starts to turn
on him
um this is this is a big deal he says uh
bring Alex Jones back what should
Twitter do next bring Alice Jones back
he says no
oh [ __ ] oh
wait are you actually on Twitter no I'm
not logged in okay
because don't scroll because
um another funny detail about all this
is if you recall Elon when back earlier
this year was talking about buying
Twitter his big like issue with it is
it's overrun with Bots it's all Bots or
whatever his replies have never had more
Bots and also you have there's just
straight up hardcore porn in his reply
like just just full dick
like cardi B last night posted a porn
video it was so funny you just scroll
through his replies you will you will
see I don't remember what you said bunch
of porn waiter dying or something and
she is like a lots of dick
just lots of dicks describe it to me and
I should describe it to me
um maybe Ian can help me I wasn't I
didn't have sound on I didn't get to see
it I only saw it looked like a lady on a
boat I don't know if he was singing it
was almost like a music video vibe but
it was porn too okay
oh there's dicks everywhere okay cool
cool that's an interesting
she found some interesting stuff it
sounds like she's been waiting for this
moment
um so here's the people's response he's
not bringing Alex Jones back if you give
freedom of speech to some but not all
you're no different than they were oh my
God how could you say that he's not
different he's worse way worse
but I thought you said people don't get
banned only specific tweets that break
the rules I don't understand oh man
wow I actually disliked the musk to eat
so you aren't for free speech got it uh
we've kind of been trying to say that
you know it's been [ __ ]
and he permanently banned both me and my
wife where's the free speech this
contradicts your free speech stance I do
not agree with Alex Jones but he needs
to be able to speak along with everyone
else you should try to justify your
position here rather than just saying no
exactly wow that's a that's actually a
deep thought
I mean it's not even really a liability
for them to have Alex Jones on like
technically if he was wanting to do Free
Speech section 230 protects him from
whatever Alex Jones post there Alex
Jones would be sued personally but
Twitter wouldn't be liable so like
legally I don't think there's a problem
now there's no problem with any of it
it's never been about that it's always
sponsors exactly it's oh and that's the
thing everybody thinks it's a the woke
left everybody works at Twitter is the
woke left it's never been about that
it's that's Corporate America baby like
all social medias that the right thinks
is like oh woke left it's literally just
people who are appeasing corporations
yes 100 across the board that is
capitalism it's actually worse now wait
wait worse and by the way cardi B posted
this after the porn video should drop my
Twitter was hacked
oh my God such a good gift
[ __ ] we missed you Wendy [ __ ]
peace and love to Wendy Williams out
there
the Hoge twins
Hodge twins
the hog twins I like it Seth Weathers
didn't think you ever went to Epstein's
Island why cave to team 10 censorship
what does that mean now he thinks he did
this is kind of the Frisbee should apply
to oh I agree Sarah Scott you know what
I say let I say let Alex Jones back on
the website it's free speech and God
damn it I'm a free speech absolutist
let them all back on why can't Twitter
be a platform for everyone exactly
pedophiles Nazis and Alex Jones let them
all back on that's why he bought Twitter
ding dongs that's why he bought Twitter
make up your mind about Free Speech then
you're being inconsistent obviously
feeling the heat from advertisers to not
unbanned trumpages I love how these
people are just so cool with him losing
44 billion but he obviously they're like
yeah bro you gotta but he's an idiot he
[ __ ] did this to himself yeah and
that's the kind of the point we made
from the day one is Trump still not back
or is he back no and he yeah in that
announcement tweet with Jordan Peterson
the follow-up was like still haven't
made a decision on Trump right he's
going to unban him yeah obviously I
don't know because he's not sure because
Trump has talked a lot of [ __ ] about
Elon and as we know he is very thin skin
so I don't Elon doesn't like Trump I
think elon's more about
having people on Twitter so I think it's
more of a thing with advertisers where
he's like they're like if you bring
Trump back that's gonna be a problem for
us I think there might be a little bit
of that right I think he's at this like
Junction of like do you save lots of
people or your girlfriend like from
Spider-Man
my ego
or my ego here because I want a lot of
people on the platform right right the
train track uh uh uh Paradox but then
Trump doesn't get along with me so keep
him back Trump called me a dumb idiot
ban him so all those statements
regarding Free Speech were just blowing
smoke yes sir yes sir that's exactly no
way that's actually [ __ ] right on
brother
um Twitter is a rat hole though so like
again I'm not I'm not upset at all not
to be on there it's actually pretty nice
uh I've been I go on there to see like
what's trending but I spend way less
time on there so it's very it's actually
really nice
um bonus
actually and a nice follow-up
we know that you're passionate about bad
tattoos Dan can you get a picture of all
the Bots Does Elon have a bad tattoo uh
yeah it's an Elon Musk tattoo it's not
on Elon Musk so here you write this for
us
um check it out oh wait hold on I gotta
mute this right here it was in the dock
actually you skipped over it okay well
let me look at this first okay
Free Speech not with the free speed
he's got no are you kidding me boring
company in the Twitter neural link Tesla
actually
Free Speech huh how did you
free speech I feel bad for this person
so delusional free speech 4 20. I also
why is tar coming out of his mouth I
think I I saw some others from the same
artist and all of them have that so I
think that's just kind of like a
signature thing he does the wild thing
is it's like that tattoo artist is
really good it's really [ __ ] good
like yeah they are I'm sorry but good
luck ever getting a date again bro
Impossible The Arc is really great but
this guy whoever is I feel really bad
for him also he's he's either has pink
irons or extremely Blaze he's supposed
to be high oh yeah from The Joe Rogan
yeah he's blazed up dude free speech
is like amazing the execution of this
yeah horrible taste great execution yeah
yeah exactly Blaze 420 Free Speech bro
Free Speech hey you said a mean joke
permanently banned
Free Speech bro here just real quick so
here is so yeah here's Elon
um well what's the Tweet show the the
mother tweet oh I didn't screenshot that
it was it was the uh it was the one last
night about um
uh what do you call it bigger yeah yeah
you gotta zoom on that
so he but one of the main reasons he
bought Twitter is because to get rid of
the Bots yeah so here's his here's his
replies so yeah I went like he had just
tweeted I forget which one it was but
one of the tweets and I scrolled down
and I saw this it's verified at Elon
Musk well this is just a screenshot
oh they're posting the screen yeah yeah
thanks a lot it says thanks a million
spelled wrong the screenshot says I
decided to randomly choose 1 000 new
followers who can participate to the
biggest crypto giveaway hurry up
tesla-grant.repel.com yeah it seems very
so scroll down yeah look at this it was
just this is his replies
like I couldn't this is the widest I
could get it on my screen there was
plenty more of it too but just uh the
the bot War does not seem to have gone
too fast you guys think I saw somebody
in the chat just say it and I started
seeing it last night on Twitter people
are saying that he faked his degrees
so I saw that too it's just this random
Reddit thread I'm curious I'm kind of
waiting to see more because it doesn't
really I don't really care it's not like
he he owns all his companions doesn't
matter what his credentials are right
but it had something to do with it is
pretty pathetic to lie about you yeah
well it's more than that it's because he
is uh he it was I assume he is now but
at the time was not a U.S citizen and so
his Visa was contingent on him being in
school and apparently he uh dropped out
at some point and never actually got the
degrees and then lied about his degrees
on his application for his work visa
would that be epic if Trump becomes
president and spite's expenses
because you know traditionally someone
like Elon Musk would have no problem
retaining for citizenship right they
lied on their papers but Trump as
president probably could Deport him yes
he said Capital Hunters post about it
they have all the receipts yeah I saw
the thread it's very interesting I'm
gonna wait for something a little bit
more it would be random too than a
Twitter thread to pick up on the story I
mean I I'm inclined to believe it
because he he is a fraudible yeah uh
yeah it would be pretty dumb to deport
the richest man in the world and despite
him paying a very low uh I don't know
what happened that would you know be not
you'd be losing some tax there
[Music]
um so there it is
that's the story
that's it that's still developing I mean
I mean again just in summary I don't see
any other possible reason that Ela got
permanently suspended other than Elon
Musk saw those tweets and acted on it
there's no way that what was I doing
wrong because the thing was I mean wrong
with me nothing I'm gonna do my devil's
attic thing right now the one tweet that
said specifically said the phrase I am
bandivating uh is it bannivating or is
it a joke
like that I'm not actually doing the
action of it's Ila's verify
impersonating that's the only thing I
can think of in any of those tweets that
I could point to and be like maybe this
is why they're justification no they did
it for bannivating they sent the the
message well there you go yeah but but
like what is the chance that he that we
get banned at like 3 A.M the morning of
Twitter having an absolute crisis yeah
no I always locked out the doors are
closed Elon reads his replies and looks
at his tab uh so I I am I'm inclined to
agree with you guys that he probably saw
it there we go he's extremely you were
poo pooing the idea at first but I think
I convinced you yeah I I think that
there's a decent chance that he saw
someone says you are bandivating how are
we Banning that's Ila's account all she
did was post a picture of me and a joke
how was that bannivating I didn't make a
new account it's literally a commenting
it's a [ __ ] joke it's literally
innovating comedy's legal Ila's account
she made a joke Banny waiting would be
me making a new account and posting from
it that was a [ __ ] joke right it's
not band evading Ela tweeted that [ __ ]
it's a joke
and I was even confident I was like no
way we're gonna get suspended because
there's like nobody left at Twitter and
then when I woke up in the morning and
it was banned I was like oh wow elon's
really just pathetic I'm saying man
it's not bad evading it's just not
probably automated how the [ __ ] are you
gonna say automated there's no shot that
was automated you just put band evading
and then they ban you there's no shot
there's literally zero percent
on my personal trending eel is number
one
oh it is
a new picture about unbannela I don't
think so yeah just as evil they better
fear you you better you better fear illa
I don't see it on mine how many tweets
does it have under it
um
sixteen hundred let's go what does it
say on there I mean maybe somebody can
get him to answer the question
it's it's probably like quartering he
dies like people interact with random
tweets
I'm sure if he saw the teddy fresh shirt
he probably has been waiting for
something oh you saw that maybe maybe
but still technically it's a joke it's a
joke yeah technically the rules should
apply even if I talk [ __ ] about him oh
hold on we have breaking uh message from
Rory Hicks who says Elon is led to the
death of millions of mole people oh the
Fila calls for war we will be there with
our drill lances as a Rory hips of the
mulch shout out to the mole people he's
Rory in the mole people
oh
Fringe on their sovereignty yeah a lot
of damage
um um Ian since you've been all over the
news can you hook me up with a reporter
right you've been talking to
yeah I know a couple to be honest
they're really shitty reporters I'm not
sure you want to talk to them
don't say that don't say that they're
kind of the worst ones so don't say that
how long we've been going we've been
going for two and a half hours
it feels longer for some reason today
no offense to you guys
yeah
just a little bit longer all right let's
do the um and let's do Ian's big story
then let me find out okay now what Ian
now uh um Ila's account got nuked while
I was sleeping
oh this is one of the tweets yeah
important that's Dan the face oh that
was for me when I was dying from the
trip yeah
yeah and for what and for what
the top tweet is uh Teddy fresh so
that's good at least wait till he spite
bands like Teddy fresh and the podcast
and everything right then you'll know
for sure by the way I have nothing to do
with either of those accounts thank you
peace and love peace and love nothing
thank you
thank you
anyway
um The Insider wrote an article about
Ian and the Kanye
subreddit now Ian
during the early ages of this show was a
huge Kanye West fan
and you used to kind of talk him up all
the time and people on the subreddit
took notice of Ian that he was a Kanye
head and actually there was a moment
when you were getting a lot of respect
in the community so much so you got
invited on a Kanye West podcast do you
wanna you wanna talk about that a little
bit no
[Laughter]
I
those those guys have excommunicated me
pretty bad who gives a [ __ ] yeah I want
to give him the clout but uh yes I was I
was esteemed yes somewhat I was somebody
yeah yeah and so much so that um
it was um one what was the occasion that
we got you modded on there someone
reached out what what's the story behind
how you got the mod uh one of the mods
on the Connie sub reached out and said
that they wanted to make me an honorary
moderator because they thought that I
was representing the community
uh well he was the that that says a lot
yeah so you got the honorary mod status
I was a beacon of terminally online
white men who care a little too much
about hip-hop to a weird degree and we
love that group The Kanye's entire fan
base yes that is a marginalized group
don't just don't don't degrade them and
so the mod list for the subreddit is
public
on the bottom of the list of like six
people
is Ian's name Ian H3
and actually they didn't know but you're
your Reddit account has no literally no
power within the subreddit you have no
access no it was basically just for show
um
they gave me a key to the city
essentially it doesn't open a single
lock right
and so
when all the Kanye West
um
controversy started happening I guess
some reporters reached out to the mods
and so how did this reporter contact you
Ian
uh yeah I got a Reddit DM from a
reporter from Insider and they were
asking for comments uh and an official
stance from the Kanye subreddit on his
recent act that's so funny and so you
took this uh what was what was your
thinking here as a person who has not
moderated a single time I thought I was
in a great position to make a statement
I asked if he had talked to any of the
other mods he said no no no responses
from the other mods yeah what made you
actually choose to reply to this Reddit
DM
I just thought it would be funny for me
to um yeah to represent them write just
the most dramatic I don't know what
they're doing over there I did not go to
that subreddit I I have not modded that
subreddit I have no idea but I made a
bunch of stuff it's all made up yeah
were you surprised they printed this yes
yeah so here's the message you sent is
this all you sent them no we had a
little backboard this is like a sample
though of like how I was communicating
he was sending me questions and this was
kind of like how I was responding so so
you want to read it or you want me to
read it I can read it he asked me what
has it been like
in the Kanye summer I said the world as
we know it is gone Die Hard fans with no
country A Flock with no Shepherd swept
out to sea with no Lighthouse to guide
these poor souls back to shore many left
this desolation for the pain was too
much seeking refuge in the distant lands
of R Frank Ocean but for those who
remain they walk amongst this Valley of
Ash and fire with eyes that do not see
for they are now Conan cusps of former
posters and they are lost so for a
reporter to actually read that and say
this is this is breaking stuff here yeah
you're obviously [ __ ] with them or
this you would expect them to think but
but they turned this into an article and
um it got re-articled this goes on like
a lot of people are reporting on this
now yeah go ahead let's read part two
Ian uh yes do I know if the mod team has
had to ban more people than usual now I
made it very clear I don't even really
mod this page they chose not to see that
yeah yeah and I said I'm not exactly
sure how many bands they're doing but
you ever seen the movie ants when the
termites attack I'd imagine it's like
that it's a bloodbath out here users are
[ __ ] posting their way to an early band
grave accounts with years of karma gone
fedoras are flying off lines in the sand
are being drawn users cradling their
graduation vinyls and sobbing into the
night sorting by controversial is a
Dante's Inferno trip to the seventh
circle Oz can try to hold the seams of
reality together but their counsel is
doomed to be cast into the abyss have
you ever seen the movie Green Lantern
it's like that one too
there's no analogy to Green Lantern
right that was just to throw it out
there or did you want to break down that
analogy well I was sort of saying like
because I was saying the mod the Council
of mods or holding the seams of reality
yeah and I was thinking of like the
Green Lantern aliens that they watch
over the universe right there's a lot of
high level activity going on on the
subreddit okay so that was a good
analogy for them to unravel yeah again a
professional journalist read this and
said let's [ __ ] go with this that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] well I want to see that
one yeah Kanye but you're right actually
the sentiment is correct
so here's the article
um
did they tell you they were going to
print this
yeah he was I sent him all the I would
send him an answer like that and he'd be
like okay cool and how has it been like
have you been seeing a lot of posts or
just he pushed through it pretty
strongly and then he told me all right
I'll let you know when it goes up those
Insider people are on a tight deadline
Kieran uh Karen press Reynolds uh
you got got here's the title a moderator
of one of the biggest Kanye West
internet forums says the page has been a
blood back since the rapper's descent
into anti-Semitism and conspiracy theory
it's interesting how that one word
really caught on fire like all of them
are saying it they love the bloodbath
yeah
over the last month and a half weird how
they left the ants part out though
I thought the Green Lantern on the end
was more uh was more apt well because he
said it's a bloodbath like in ants so it
was specifically related so I don't know
it was such a good analogy I don't know
why they left that out oh yeah so the
rate of form has over 700 000 members
over the last month and a half the
musician yay has uh sparked backlash for
a flurry of incidents and Center spoke
with Ian Slater a 28 year old honorary
moderator okay so they said they said
honorary
yes
now what
the Slate said the pages turned into a
bloodbath with many users getting banned
Kanye yeah so
it goes on you could skip down
um a little bit the world as we know it
is gone because moderator of Kanye
you're [ __ ] done I don't know what to
say but y'all are actually like so silly
for posting for writing this and they
can't drop me and Center spoke to
insulator 28 year old moderator who was
once a huge fan but said he isn't
anymore he said he has converted to a
Charlie x-wise XCX guy after yeah he's
just sent into conspiracy theories it's
true Slader slate oh yeah Slater is also
a producer and staff member of ethink
Line's H3 podcast which is where he said
that our Kanye Reddit team found him
because he often spokes about yay Slayer
is an Honore which means he has no
access he has
access to some tools that's not true is
it it like they gave me the most like
basic level like I could Mark a thing as
spam it says removing and approving new
posts you can do that
uh I think I can like you can approve
this you're gonna prove it if it gets
caught in the Auto mod filter but yeah
it's it's like the lowest level you can
get he doesn't exercise them the other
moderators granted him the prestigious
status as a gift because he was a vocal
yay fan so he even says in here I don't
want this page essentially Slater's uh
described a die-hard fans as Citizens
with no country the world as we know it
is gone he said oh hey here come come
come get me I can't believe they're
quote I can't believe this article for
those who remain posting commenting on
our Kanye Slater said they walk amongst
this Valley of Ash and fire with eyes
that do not see you cannot be [ __ ]
serious yes Jesus Walks baby Slater says
many fans turn critics have left the
form and taken refuge in the subreddit
of Frank Ocean
this is crazy what are you doing it's
all about you Ian it's like literally
all based on your interview I made sure
to give my full name because I was like
I'm I'm gonna use this yeah this is
getting that check mark amazing nice
Beautiful Dark Twisted fast
I think you shouldn't
um insult the journalist so much because
this is like they've given us such a
beautiful gift yeah you better hope they
don't take it down no no I mean look
towards towards him look I mean on one
hand yes but on the other hand I mean we
talk about journalists and you do a
better job here and uh to protect
democracy and uh well
out of curiosity I did go to that
subreddit and just to get a gauge of
what people are saying yeah a lot of
people are against what he's saying but
if you do sort by controversial on all
of these posts there's some [ __ ] going
on yeah it's all very downvoted but
there are a lot of
high level conversations happening I can
imagine a community say anti-semitic
[ __ ] nope
again he continued I mean this is all
yes it just keeps crazy there's really
nothing but it's just it's about Ian
funny it's the whole article
when asked his stance on yay's
anti-Semitism other controversy Slater
said he didn't support yay's recent
actions and was done acting as a
full-time publicist for the musician it
was basically me saying that to you
Ethan I'm resigning I know you keep
trying but I keep asking
I'll keep that the final the final
thoughts yeah like at the end of the day
you know more about him than any of us
so I still think like you know you are
an authority
you wrote the I mean you wrote a
screenplay about his life right
look I've got some I've got some article
links I can send you and you just read
those all right okay all right the
president
yes so um
very funny very crazy good job Ian made
a great segment here for the show
and then
so n
oh yeah
we'll throw back
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
amazing what now is nme like a
prestigious yeah it's big music press uh
so UK this is so silly and they reposted
the article rewrote about it Kanye West
moderator says Pages become a bloodbath
and then later revealed he's stepping
down it's basically the same [ __ ]
reprinted right yeah different different
authors on all these
they got the easy job man what are they
just [ __ ] and there's another one
from the Independent
they kind of they kind of print
everything don't they I think Instagram
asks for three articles Ian I know boom
done boom one two three documentary that
Candace always put up one of the things
that his two rules let's not look become
a bloodbath again Kanye West moderators
of rappers biggest Reddit form says the
pages become a bloodbath now what some
users are [ __ ] posting their way to
early band he said
again like you said Dan an ants like an
ant like an ant ants the movie it really
evokes like a the image because I
remember that movie and the bloodbath I
mean the the termites they spitting acid
it was uh hundreds of ants they're just
getting burned alive and it's brutal it
was like Saving Private Ryan yeah with
ants like the Kanye sobriety yeah
exactly
and then finally
oh they've used a picture of you here
someone oh this is a sponsored post on
Facebook really oh
Kings of a r you know what would have
been best is the one of you in the
background of the picture with Kanye
that would have been awesome
come at me this is the most like Reddit
mod looking man yeah exactly I'm wearing
a I own bill Delphine spit
it's a guy that's online a lot they
really got cool ass dude that's a cool
ass dude right there they got you good
actually you're right
and so word comes around to the Kanye
West subreddit and they are not happy
with Ian
at all I mean the comments have actually
flopped I think when they realized it
was a joke yeah and I went and I made a
little comment in there but
um if you were to sort by controversial
I'm sure you'd see some stuff it's an
anti-semitic thing I think that's
exactly what I would see right yeah well
Dan I didn't look at the comments before
it when it was like all pure Kanye stuff
it was you're saying I was catching a
lot of heat yeah more than Ian yeah
Ethan has nothing to do with this
situation nothing and all the comments
was like oh he works for each three [ __ ]
Ethan Klein
it's just like what they're like okay no
it makes sense yeah now it makes sense
nothing to do with that one yeah but so
if 5 000 upvotes that's that's a lot for
that when you started by being Jewish
first problem huge bro issue number one
here oh that you got sticky is this your
comment no that this was uh one of the
mods there uh he does link to Ethan's or
to Ian's comment yeah
from the History Podcast who I made
honorary mod in 2018 for shits and
giggles it seems like Insider
approaching because of comments he
recently made on the well-known podcast
today Ian explained his blood Beth
comment here
which I'll open in a separate window and
has decided to step down as an honorary
moderator we wish him the best of luck
and we'll be expecting apology on
tomorrow's podcast for squeezing every
bit of clout out of his honorary mod
title refusing to do so result in a
class action lawsuit filed on Kanye cork
what the [ __ ] is Kanye Court I don't
know
holy [ __ ] these guys are in deep let me
speak on it
it's a joke probably it's probably a
joke yeah
that's a real subreddit it exists I mean
yeah but I
um
you have to read my my statement's
basically what I said here and these
screenshots I showed just saying that I
was just [ __ ] damn I missed I wish
you guys captured some of the people who
are really angry because now it's just
like H3 memes because I got
cross-referenced oh just sort by
controversy but there was ones like
which which one of you [ __ ] mods did
this out there somewhere yeah I can yeah
definitely like genuine anger it should
be you're let me go controversial all
right give it a shot I'm going in
I'm going in with scary
what clout chasing mod did this
has it really been a blood blast though
we don't know Ian never actually went
there
sure as a moderator I'm sure he has seen
the worst of it but nearly all the
threat in the concept scene that our
anti-semitic racist even pro-mag are
heavily downloaded uh it's a bloodbath
Insider wrote it so [ __ ] you you're
wrong
Kanye said nothing wrong okay
cool which one of you mods is bitching
some guy named Ian Slater apparently who
works for HP podcast
Ian I love you that's just uh it's a
good thing
oh I love you
but you have made it clear several times
you don't like you anymore and that was
a long before all the stuff went on I
think it's time you depart for being a
mod
ouch we did he resigned he's out yeah
uh here I just found one some guy named
Ian Slater 28 wrote Reddit mod who also
happens to work on the History Podcast
with Ethan Klein and then reply to that
that makes so much sense also [ __ ] Ethan
and [ __ ] h3h
wow I love that I love that somehow Ian
what do you think about that it's like
oh he works for Ethan that make that
explains Ian's complete character as a
human being yeah
we are all sort of intrinsically linked
to you forever that's actually true uh
sorry to tell you guys you're pretty
much yeah linked to me forever we're
essentially like there's like nine
horcruxes in this room
that's true I'll live forever through
you all
um anyone who's still a part of H3 screw
is lame is H3 himself like dude went
from ripping the fattest clouds to
letting himself go and sitting around
giving bro wait what these people think
Vape Nation wasn't a joke like this is
what we're dealing with he was ripping
the baddest clouds like he thought that
was cool yes oh he's no he is let me
finish this ripping the fattest clouds
to letting himself go and sitting around
giving service level takes about Ukraine
and Andrew Tate
come on man make some comedy or at least
some better merch better merge
shots fired at Eli
let me see a picture of you
and yeah show exactly before you call me
fat I need to analyze your body and what
are you wearing let's see your Vape
clouds bro yeah bro [ __ ] weakness
yeah let me see the size of your cloud
oh I will say that they added onto my my
statement they gave me a flare Uh custom
flare and it's just a clown Emoji let me
pull it up
oh I got owned hold on let me open this
so they're actually mad it seems like
they give you the clown pretty much
there it is oh my God honestly I think
it's H3 fans who are who are came to the
thread to support you I think the Kanye
guys are actually pissed yeah
probably here's another one about you
Ethan
you're a horrible Ethan is a horrible
Disturbed sick human being who calls for
the canceling of people he doesn't like
constantly lies about others laughed at
Jordan Peterson when he almost lost his
life due to drugs and and that dude well
I'm gonna skip this one uh something
about Ben Shapiro uh
says the exercise uh says that exercise
is useless there it is
and somehow white supremacists know that
wait I'm a white Supreme no no saying
that exercise is useless and somehow
white supremacist oh yeah exercising is
white supremacy look it up do your
research folks it benefits the white uh
I don't know
of course by the way also with racist as
[ __ ] to Gideon
what wait I was racist to jidian no
wait what did I say my sister Jordan
okay Ethan is actually racist in a piece
of [ __ ] yep
awesome so shout out I let dude my
haters like my passionate haters of
which there's it's like a growing number
now they really live in this wild uh
alternate universe uh where I'm like
I don't know like how I'm like an aunt
as like somehow I'm woke but also racist
right
I'm woke but also I don't know it's like
it just makes no sense it's like crazy
it's like a caricature
um so that that was great I mean
congratulations Ian that was that was
well done that was really that was fun a
masterpiece
bonus meme
oh one more time
[Music]
yeah Nathaniel klansman I believe that I
preferably refer to
oh yeah Gideon had that click bait
thumbnail about me being racist oh yeah
and he changed right but it wasn't much
better so there you go people think I'm
racist because that's stupid because of
the thumbnail there you go thanks bro
that's some [ __ ] that was funny
[Music]
no we stand Gideon
right W Dan at least I do yeah speaking
of what one final uh Kanye meme he's
hanging out with Milo yianopolis we were
talking about him he's a right-wing
provocateur who went on he got cancer
everyone on Joe Rogan and talked about
how he enjoyed being molested by a
priest and all this is pretty crazy so
Kanye's hanging out with him he is the
lowest of the low in terms of right-wing
provocateur uh white supremacist
Christian nationalists just freaks dude
he's wearing the Adidas Balenciaga
collab and I thought he's got beef with
Adidas
where's your spine I think he I think in
a weird way he
is like defiant I don't know he's trying
to be defined I don't think so because
his like at least from comments that I
see on Instagram his like dedicated
stance they all hate Adidas now
yeah yeah and supposedly they're
fighting over the easy designs his
lawyer said he has the rights to it and
Adidas said no they have the rights they
said they plan on running those designs
under a new brand is so awesome they
just say they own it it's not his I'm
sure Adidas own it if they say like
those [ __ ] don't [ __ ] around
Adidas come on I just thought it was
kind of funny to see him wearing it but
why is it what do you make of this Dan
uh he's hanging out with Milo
I mean it shouldn't be too surprising I
guess the most surprising thing is it is
not that he's hanging out with somebody
like Milo but that I mean Milo [ __ ]
as far as being a right-wing piece of
[ __ ] on the internet has fallen off hard
like nobody really cares about him
anymore
he joined like a Christian yeah he's
like yeah or CV what do you call the QVC
yeah you joined a Christian QV it's
crazy and he's like he's like super like
Catholic now or something he's like his
Capital he says he's not gay anymore
right he's flamboyant he is so good
Jesus uh cured his his gayness you know
even straight Milo he's like so
flamboyant and so gay
it's fantastic oh no yeah and sad also
thank you Cookie for the 10 gifted I
mean at this point Kanye just hangs out
with anybody that will hang out with him
I think so yeah you know he he needs he
needs Yes Men yeah these are this just
shows you the kind of people that are
around now
he's just cruising sipping champagne
like it's all good
somebody said Milo used to rip the
fattest bigotry
that's good uh Matt Harry thank you for
the five gifted let's have a pride
minute for Milo it's been a minute it's
been a while okay I think I think
I think we need to pray for Milo
ayalo yiannopoulos
it's okay man you don't have to convert
because there's nothing wrong with you
Dave rubin's and married gay guy yeah
exactly be like Dave Rubin you can be a
[ __ ] you can be a grifter show and also
be openly gay
month come on man it's 2022. let's just
be yourself there's nothing better than
a big fat juicy [ __ ] [ __ ] bro okay
yes just think about it it's like a
delicious hot pie it's just a big old
bucket and it's shaved down to the skin
like avian Hassan
no hair and the balls [ __ ] please
baby you shave your [ __ ] too baby
don't need to
Milo I just I need just be proud god
listen you didn't being gay is nothing
wrong it's a beautiful thing in fact the
diversity of The Human Experience is
beautiful we love it I love you just the
way you are and that's time yeah but get
you know what back in the [ __ ]
Christian CV
bro get the gay out of your system and
get the back [ __ ] back to work
[Music]
embarrassing your friends
foreign
to 30 seconds this shit's way too gay up
in this
[Music]
back in the closet Milo
shame on you
think you are how dare how dare you how
dare you spit in God's face like that
you're getting back in the closet and
stay there Lord this is this is your
preacher Milo
that's the stairway you'll never climb
if you touch the dick that ain't yours
boy
now let me tell you something Milo I
know you've been molested by that
preacher and you liked it
we moved him to another church and I
swear to God he only done it three times
since then
to be clear that was what Milo said
that's not Ethan saying that that's what
Milo said that he enjoyed it I think not
everybody has them people if people
don't well he did say it earlier but I
just want to make that very clear oh it
said on Joe Rogan he was molested when
he was a child by a priest and he
thought it was a positive you liked it
he liked it it was part of what made it
got him canceled because then he he he
was like I think all uh young men should
have relationships with older men he was
basically saying like pedophilia good
he's like that was a good relationship
that I would like to replicate from the
other side right which was really sad
think about it like it's just a victim
that's
not come to terms with yeah the real
he's very Scottish
thank you Audrey for that
yes sure for sure uh real quick um I
received a message from one of the mods
on Reddit he said Dan check your DMs
okay yeah is there anthra no are they
gonna are they gonna make me a mom
jacket it could be a bunch of dirt on
Ian
checking my DMs on uh thank you for the
10 gifted by the way oh my God what's
going on I like never back it off never
go on here yeah we love our uh lgbtq uh
so [ __ ] shame
that any old made to feel lesser than
or wrong
[Music]
um we are waiting for Dan to check his
DMs I mean I'm looking
what's happening I'm waiting for my DMs
too on Twitter my DMs are a mess because
uh
I also get all like the mod messages in
there so it's okay I'm just checking
into it I'm just on Twitter no big deal
I'm still suspended yo wonders yeah me
too yo
what is it you found it
hold on what that looks super excited
yeah there's a lot of joints
I am now a moderator
so somebody's watching the show here
well yeah I mean somebody on their staff
is a fan because that's how they
originally knew about Ian but that
that's funny because they all hate my
guts well the people the posters I don't
know but they're gonna go they're gonna
lose their mind when they see Danza mod
he's even more Dan's even more woke than
me he's a straight up lib the NH3 baby
and you even got a flare which is uh
Kanye saying praise I do miracles on
meter he does miracles on me or
something I don't know oh yeah what's
the angels on my body or what is that
yeah oh
uh what is this a miracle zombie we used
to say right or
what I don't know Zach would know he
used to play that goals
on yeah yeah he does Miracles what and
then says immediately what it is
so congratulations Dan all right thank
you thank you I've always I you know
I've always been a big supporter wait
where's Mr Kanye West I've always
thought Ayla trending and so I was
looking at Dan's like I felt gay based
on what they mean I I felt yeah just
based on what they told me
Ian you're being very gracious about
this
are you are you happy for Dan it's the
passing of the torch yeah it's sort of a
Obi-Wan Anakin moment
he will do the role
Justice I'm looking forward to your
press tour Dan that's gonna be really
fiery yo they're gonna reach up you
write it Insider reach out
an article I have thoughts this
character to come back there is a hunger
for another H3 cast member to be a mod
this character to come back our hunger
has been Associated
they should have interviewed Oliver too
he was a mod on there for about a day on
the WhatsApp group oh could somebody
post that link that you posted what's up
oh oh my God I saw this the other day
this is the most
do you know what this is I do it's so
much to explain yeah well okay here I
sent it and uh
so um this was the owner of the FTX that
big crypto exchange it just went under
he's like a criminal legit okay
apparently I look like him I mean the
hair for sure
and then this was this his girlfriend
so she worked at the company too and she
is also a giant piece of [ __ ] and
[ __ ] super weird
um so that's us and also I think it's
very unfair to compare Yola to her
because she's one of the most
unfortunate looking human beings I've
ever seen in my life I wasn't gonna say
it wasn't going to say that is that okay
she is simultaneously 14 and a 55 year
old woman I'd say that and what about me
I wouldn't have any sympathy for me Dan
well he's not I mean you know he's a
little unfortunate looking but like
Jesus
with her yeah but I see the resemblance
I'll play them in the movie just hit us
up whatever yeah I'm sure the comments
are going to be super [ __ ] gracious
yeah I'm sure the yeah that section is
great let's see here
and I normally would not say uh
something so mean about a person's looks
but um she is a [ __ ] huge piece of
[ __ ]
yeah she stole
like millions and millions of dollars
from people and is also just a mega
right-wing crypto Griffith oh she is
yeah she probably sounds like this
oh this is my wallet
yeah I hope they both uh rot uh for what
you know her breath is [ __ ] beast
look at that [ __ ] time to invest
well I'm so glad what a what a great day
what a great show I'm so glad that
um Jordan Peterson Andrew Tate are back
on Twitter for spreading
um hate against marginalized groups
yet uh
we remain
permanently banned
Andrew Tates being suggested to me on
three profile uh profiles say what what
Andrew Tate's being suggested to me
comedy is back baby
[Applause]
I love it comedy was illegal before Elon
Musk now comedy is legal now it's legal
baby oh well what's some asterisks like
um
uh don't joke about certain topics don't
mention anyone don't uh impersonate Elon
don't be mean don't believe me Mean
Tweets will uh are not allowed you will
get Shadow banned if you're mean right
but you can't be mean but the soul
depression of English of course yeah I'm
the one getting plowed
this is your um suggested follows on
three different accounts no this is just
one account oh you can get promoted to
try to get some people to follow you
that's interesting I don't even know you
could do that who would pay for that
yeah exactly only a freak got out
leftovers out of context though shout
out they're gonna get banned
impersonating
cover tape congratulations buddy
uh welcome back man so glad he hasn't
paid that eight bucks yet huh
all right are you did you we're about
done does your mouse Want to Say Goodbye
Dan or
so I realized why I did it and why it
never happened before I guess the the
driver thing like Auto updated and was
running a little program
300 DPI yeah
close it
300 DPI
so uh API not 300 DPI there you go
that's good that's just as good
300 DPI
all right thank you guys oh wait it just
reopened here we go
[Music]
800 3200 DPR there it is DPI
DPI
1600 to DPI Windows 600 DBI 1 000 3200
to DPI DPI
it's a lot of dpis dude 6400 DPS oh he's
getting intense wow oh he's getting it
there's another wait there's another
level
8200 DPI
all right guys have a good weekend 1 600
DBI it was a fun week good shows
you know thanks for being here everybody
Tuesday for members
I'm live live stream for the members
nice and do we have anything planned for
next week let's uh look forward to
Thanksgiving yeah it's kind of a weird
uh week so there'll be episodes on
Monday and Wednesday as normal it's true
TV and off the rails uh however
um Thursday is obviously
Thanksgiving so there won't be leftovers
and then Friday we won't be live but we
will be pre-recording our traditional
you laugh you lose episode on Tuesday
and then we will post that on Friday so
there will be a Friday episode and kind
of a special let's it's a podcast
special yeah it's a fun it's a fan
favorite it's always fun we do it it's a
tradition by the way people were mad on
leftovers that me and Hassan did not do
how to talk to your family your
conservative family we're gonna do it
for Christmas we're going to do that a
Christmas special yeah conservative
family everyone at home uh I got one
message real fast from Megan she says
dan check your Instagram DM my sis sent
proof that 23andMe said me and my sister
are related to both Ethan and Ben
Shapiro
there's no [ __ ] shot what was the
name
I'm gonna go stand it in nuclear reactor
until the DNA related to bench Bureau
gets shot out of my body what was the
name of it I don't know who she didn't
say she said my sister
uh because my
I never look in my Instagram DMS and I
have 10 buchillas medicine I mean it's
supposed to be recent I see the most
recent five hours ago so it couldn't
have been that
oh yeah hidden or on just like on
message requests on all requests
don't see it sorry all right everybody
see on Monday all right it's party time
yes happy birthday to Gabe have a great
uh weekend everybody and uh take care
see ya
[Music]
foreign
[Music]